to the FL of the United States of
America for it stands one nation under
God indivisible liy and justice for all
thank you morning
everyone need to read the
uh
notice as chair of the labor industrial
and rehabilitative services committee I
find that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
covid-19 pandemic and in accordance with
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuing to
executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
have ability to
[Music]
chairman
distorted saying I can't hear
they're saying there's
sound what kind of sound
issues uh it sounds like it's it's all
static and broken up when you same as
last week try leaning back from the mic
a little
bit we're having um microphone issues I
guess oh that's that's better that's
better close you pushing a button in
you're messing with
us hold on guys just uh you don't have
to be right up in front of it that's not
of problem just um just sit back from it
and you'll be fine is that better folks
yes that's it sit back and relax even a
little
further all right thank you that's
perfect
perfect the window all right I will read
descript again folks as chair of the
labor and Industrial and rehabilitative
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covid-19 pandemic in
accordance with house rule 67 the
governor emergency order number 12 pursu
to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee an
executive session may follow please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to the meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and elected legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen in and if
necessary participate in the meeting bya
Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
available to the house available in the
house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meet the
notice for this meeting notice complies
in house rule RSA
91a anyone who has problems accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email get your pens ready
HCS ledge. state. n. Us phone number is
271 3600 or HCS at ledge l. state.
n.us in the event the public is unable
to access the meeting the meeting will
be adjourned and rescheduled Christine
Dyer is our staff assisting us today
please note all votes that are taken
during the meeting shall be done by roll
call vote let's start the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please also
State whether there is anyone in the
room with you during this meeting which
is required by the RO right to no
law Mr clerk
inventory here in the L sewor here and
alalani where are
you
muted all right go
please uhum here in the
L Mary
here
nunz
else here l be D roian
substance I'm at home on Zoom by
myself ly here
L HFF here L
Sullivan here uh home in my in my home
office
alone Susy here in my dining room
alone Rudy here my home office and you
will hear my dog he's been acting
up K
Hill home in New Market thank you
late I'm sorry
Smith I'm here in my home office
here in my home office
alone thank you do you have a quorum yes
do thank you very much I like to um
introduce house bill or excuse me I'd
like to open the hearing on House Bill
113 and ask representative Michael
kahill to introduce this bill under
understanding uh that Michael is no
longer technically sitting as a state
representative here will not be able to
ask questions of himself
or so go ahead go ahead representative
kahill thank you very much Mr chairman I
am Mike we can't hear you here in the
LLB if you can get either closer okay
got it I'm using this fancy Gizmo here
is that better not much bar oh my okay
let me how's that
[Music]
up AP apologize here for the uh a bit
better that's better that's better okay
who knows uh okay thank you Mr chairman
I am Michael kahill representing the
town of New Market and new fields in
Rockingham 17 here once again to
introduce uh and it's deja all over
again at the risk ofing a Yankee Yogi
Bara uh introduce a bill to HB
113 relative to payment for earned but
unused vacation or personal time uh as I
wrote to you uh last evening this was a
repre of a bill that we worked on last
term and passed uh out of committee and
to the floor uh and and out to the
Senate where it did not get on any of
the onuses so we are back today to talk
about this bill uh I've also given you
materials um citing you know many of the
situations where an
employee um loses what they've earned
and and they they do earn this they know
these are these are wages that they
earned and in many well in many cases uh
the employer will will pay them what was
left on their ped up the vacations and
such uh in other cases it doesn't happen
and this is because it's at the up to
the employer policy which in some cases
I think we would agree uh is abused and
I've given you examples of those and uh
I hope that you will read and understand
them and see that uh we could address
this once and for all by putting
everyone on the same page and knowing
that once once the vacation time is
earned it belongs to the employee and
and and then should be paid out
regardless of the circumstances of the
uh termination of employment whether
they uh give notice don't give notice uh
even if they're let go and we're
assuming that they were they they were
good employees and and earning that uh
vacation up until the time they were let
go uh again this is uh this has been the
law in Massachusetts for over a century
and I know we don't do everything they
do in Massachusetts but I hope we'll do
this one uh there's a lot of work uh at
the department of labor on this issue
alone and I believe Mr Ogden will speak
to that when he uh takes that witness
chair virtual chair any questions I'll
be happy to answer
them representative kill uh there's a
question here in the uh lb
representative agent thank you Mr
chairman uh thank the member for taking
the question um just looking over this
um this looks like it applies to um as
we just discussed in termination um some
employers have um endof year policies
where vacation time lapses uh and it's
almost like if you don't use it you lose
it um is this is that applicable in this
uh legislation as well or does this just
revolve around termination thank you
representative for the question uh that
was part of the original bill which last
year the committee uh moved that was
uh a good idea but really over really
wasn't going to work so this is the use
or lose is still happening this is only
when you leave the company or you're
laid off that whatever you have left on
okay uh there any questions for resent
kill in the committee
room see no more folks I have to plug in
my computer um has gone out of battery
so I have to look across the room
and I don't see any hands
raised I do have one question for the
presenter representative kahill is this
an All or Nothing bill for you that you
would um only accept it if every single
line one through
15 were to be
approved uh thank you Mr chairman I I'm
interested in you know and edit says
they may be needed we did work hard on
this with three work sessions last year
and that is this is the exact same uh
wording um but I'm amenable if if we
will accomplish the the overarching goal
uh in preserving the earnings of the
employee I'd certainly be willing to
listen I I know there was some concern
expressed previously about when somebody
is fired you know for cause but you know
cause isn't defined in our rsas and it
could be anything you know we're in at
will state and uh but if if you have
another idea I'd be willing to
listen right thank you I have a question
here in the committee room
representative Hof you recognize for the
question thank you Mr chairman uh
representative I have a question on uh
uh number two where it says provides a
means through which vacation time
request and approvals our
process
that I'm not really sure that that has
much to do with what it is that you're
you're asking for my understanding is is
you just want folks to be able to after
they've approved uh vacation time if
they're uh separate from their
employment that they would get um that
back in in monetary form so I I don't
really understand why uh two is there to
me that sounds like they're asking for
their vacation when they're there and
it's whether or not the company approves
it I just don't see how that drain to
the rest of the
bill so I guess I just is it I'm I'm
just where am I reading this wrong uh
thank you representative for the
question well I I think this is actually
fairly standard practice but people
should know you know how they have to go
about asking for V for time off there is
a one of the incidents I I sent you
there was a a case where someone asked
for the time off and it was repeatedly
denied because of you know the needs of
the company and then when uh when she
left she couldn't get her vacation pay
so normally there's a process where you
you request it and it's approved and
this is sort of not that unusual um
again I think it's just sort of a common
sense thing that most people are
probably most employers probably do
anyway but it's just letting the people
know how it should be done and that
there is a
process
follow followup um so I just I want to
be clear to my understand what I'm
seeing here is not the idea that the
vacation time has been earned and is
already the employees to have what I'm
seeing is legislation that is
saying
that they're having an issue trying to
figure out when they're going to take
their time if they're still there see
what I'm saying yeah that's that's not
Sor thank you that's that's not the
issue we that's not the primary issue
but I think this just uh sort of fits in
with you
know how how an employer and employee
understand you know the granting the
request and granting of a vacation and
how much they have left you know on
their in their in their Bank Etc so I I
think this is not really an additional
uh an additional issue it's really just
part of the
same thank you
represent any further questions in the
L any questions on Zoom well I think I
saw Mr
tum Mr tumy represent T you recognize
your question thank you Mr chairman uh
this past the last session in the labor
committee 14-2 and then it passed the
house why isn't it law what happened uh
we had a
pandemic Mr Tumi and and the Senate
looked at all the bills they had coming
over and all their own bills and they
said uh we can't do all of this and some
of them were given priority and others
were not the next bill we be be talking
about is in another of these
instances thank
you thank you representative Tumi any
further
questions no thank you all right seeing
none thank you representative kill I'm
going to call our next uh speaker and
then I apologize for the visual I have
to go mess around with some cords here
to plug in my computer so next um as um
Ry Ogden assistant commissioner
Department Employment Securities
Department yeah no Department of Labor I
us wa wa wait where is he uh oh I I am
thank you uh can you guys hear me yes
can thank you for the record my name is
Rudy Ogden Deputy Commissioner
Department of Labor um I just want to
speak briefly to this bill uh in echoing
what uh representative Cahill said this
is something that comes up quite often
at the Department of Labor uh for
purposes of context in New Hampshire
there are no Baseline benefits law
essentially there is no law or
requirement that employers provide
vacation time or annual time or sick
time or things of that nature
accordingly in statute specifically RSA
435 uh there is language that says that
these things uh become wages when do in
application that has meant that the
employer has the ability through policy
or practice to Define uh when these are
due and owing uh that is the type of
language that allows an employer to set
certain conditions or certain parameters
that have to be met in order for the
employee to enjoy the benefits just in
terms of volume because I know some of
you do like um to deal with data and
deal with numbers uh typically the
Department of Labor we handle about 250
to 300 wage claims a year wage claims
are not us doing an inspection or
investigation and then bringing an
employer uh to a hearing wage claims are
when an employee calls the department or
files a claim with the Department saying
that they are owed something uh of the
250 to 300 wage claims that are actually
brought forward each year and brought to
hearing anywhere from 20 to 30% of those
might have a component of paid time off
in play um I just would note that
hearings oftentimes have multiple issues
so the employee might be complaining
about lost vacation time and some other
issue but again for purposes of
transparency about 20 to 30% of the
claims involve uh pay time off or
vacation time and I would just note in
speaking with employees on this matter
uh some of them I believe when they get
the policy they either don't read the
policy or when they get the policy they
don't agree with the policy uh so it's
just something that even though we try
to educate those folks on what the law
is uh they are pretty insistent on
bringing the claims forward because
again they feel as though the time is
there and should be paid uh so I'm happy
to answer any questions but again just
for purposes of context this is
something that comes up and I do think
when it comes up it's worth remembering
that there's no requirement that uh
annual or vacation time be provided it
really is the employer through policy uh
programs do I have any questions here in
the L for representative aen uh Vice
chairman uh seaworth thank you Mr Mr
chairman and thank you Deputy
Commissioner for providing your data um
my question is has in are you aware of
the department ever
encountering um a company who has
essentially an uncapped vacation
policy UNCA in terms of no limit on the
acrs right um I will be honest in saying
I'm not Direct directly aware of an
employer who has an uncapped acral
system they might be out there I'm just
saying I've not directly dealt with an
employer with no
cap follow up
and likewise I I'm not aware of a New
Hampshire employer personally that does
that I have seen it in other states and
so my question is I'm kind of wondering
how the department would deal with such
an employer and the idea of PR rating
vacation time when essentially it's
unlimited uh thank you for the question
representative seaworth in terms of our
what we believe the application of this
pration language would be is if the idea
is is that it's not AC crude and it's
instead given out in tranches such as
every year you get two weeks our
understanding would be is that the
person's time in the position we would
say Okay they've been in the position a
year they get two weeks they've been in
in the position six months they get one
week they've been in the position four
years they get uh two years they get up
to four weeks so that's our
understanding of what the proci language
here is um meaning again I don't mean to
speak for representative Cahill but
that's our understanding of the intent
that he has put forward relative to
pration just that absent in a cruel
system you'd be using pration to say
any other questions here in the
Zoom don't see any hands uh Mr Ogden I
have a question will infantine um this
is this piece of legislation
specifically talks about vacation
time what how will this
affect companies that don't technically
have a vacation time they have X amount
of hours that can be used for anything
vacation sick personal time they you
know they give them 15 days for all of
these things some employers do
that you does that need to be delineated
here uh chairman infantine I think the
thank you for the question that is
something representative kahill
reference the fact that there were
multiple SE uh work sessions last year
on this bill and that is something that
was discussed I would say that for our
purposes where it says vacation time we
again in RSA 275
435 when we're talking about these types
of benefits we do say vacation time
personal time sick time if there's just
a universal bucket that has at times
come up as an issue if you're not able
to attribute it outward so for your
question when we look at vacation time
under this bill we would be looking look
at something where it's cataloged as
vacation time so if it's not cataloged
as vacation time to your point that's
something potentially Worth delimitating
delineating or
defining okay thank
you any other questions here in the
lob any questions on
Zoom see man thank you very much thank
you signed up to speak next is uh Mr
Gary Abbott from the associated general
contractors who oppos the bill Mr Abbott
are you with us I see your symbol yes
thank you uh chairman infantine
committee members for the record my
name's Gary Abbott I'm the Executive
Vice President of the associated general
contractors of New Hampshire um I'm here
today in opposition to the bill um kind
of a little bit of a repeat of a bill
you had earlier uh we are in support of
companies devel veloping their own
office policies to address these issues
uh whether it be vacation sick time
personal time uh this bill starts to
Cloud the issue of regulations by the
state uh many employers have different
regulations regarding vacation time uh
some employers give vacation time but
have in their policies they can't use it
for a period of time um this seems to be
in conflict with that there are many
cases where um some of these things are
grouped together um I think we're kind
of heading into trying to draft uh State
policy for office policies that are
developed by companies so overall as I
listen to uh the Department of Labor I'm
not so sure that justifies the the
number of cases I don't see those number
of cases as a
reason that this is a huge problem uh it
seems like there's a problem that the
employee does doesn't understand the
office policies uh that are given to
them office policies cover lots of
issues including retirement and other
items so uh we're here today to uh leave
it with up to the company to develop
their own
policies and with that I would hope that
you would uh report this bill uh House
Bill 113 uh in expedient to legislate
and be happy to answer any
questions I have any questions for the
Zoom uh I see representative Broody has
his hand up representative Broody you're
speak thank you Mr chairman
um Mr adbert um when especially
contractors sometimes contractors have
to work more than five days a week and
they work a lot of overtime and maybe
some of these contractors pay by the
days work or hours work is how they acrw
their vacation time and if you're
opposing the bill are you opposing that
when the person leaves the employee that
um there could be a reason why the
employer doesn't want to pay vacation
time I I I think what I am saying is uh
first of all most the construction
employers have vacation sick time
retirement benefits and all the rest um
I guess what I'm relaying to you is in
the construction industry it's much more
complicated based on season based on uh
the extra hours their policies can be a
lot more complicated than a simple uh
regular 9-to-5 business and we really
want to preserve that those companies
have their options in developing their
own company policies around what type of
work they do so I I I hear what you're
saying and I will tell you most of the
construction companies have clear and
set policies we even have as an
association an HR committee uh with all
the HR professionals uh I represent
large commercial uh they understand that
in a dispute the issue goes to the labor
department and there's an interpretation
of the company's office policies we
think that's the right way to go that's
what we've done for many many years and
we' like to continue
that I hope that answered your
question
uh I'll take that for right now but I
I'm just trying to follow up yeah I'm
trying to wrap my arms around why when
somebody leaves an employ that they
don't get their full vacation time
that's coming to them and I think that's
what this bill is trying to do I I think
to answer that is really a major concern
is lines 13 through 13 and 14 um for any
any reason uh there may be appropriate
reasons to have an office policy that
vacation time is not given I know in
previous hearings I've heard of other
companies that had those policies where
uh if you leave me high and dry on a uh
something that has to get done or have
to cover the thing it may be outlined in
the policy that you don't get your
benefits and you have to understand that
policy and that's to protect what the
Company's trying to do so that specific
one is very very specific and there may
be instances in which companies uh that
that kind of flies in the face of uh
policy I see a a question hand from
representative Smith you're um
recognized for a
question did Mr Bui uh did
representative Bui finish his question
yeah go ahead okay thank you hello Mr
Abit good to see you again or or to hear
you anyway um if you'll Check Line
number five you'll see that the policy
that the company has is important
whether it applies to you will get
vacation you won't vac get vacation it
the policy is written and so um lines
number uh 12 through 13 uh really
reflect the fact that the policy drives
this um does that make
sense uh I I think I understand what
you're saying but I think the whole
intent here is starting to develop State
statutes to put in place company
policies and I think overall as a bigger
picture uh we're not sure that's a great
idea uh in the sense that companies are
different you have any followup restive
SMI are you all
right okay thank you I don't see any
other hands on Zoom or any other
questions here
lob Mr abber this is will infantine I
have a question for you um you mentioned
in your te well first off I think you
heard my question of Mr kahill Senator
representative kahill whether or not he
would accept All or nothing on this uh
every line of this piece of
legislation and my
question has to do with that to you as
well um you mentioned in your testimony
four times you want to preserve what is
written by the company manual or what
they have you don't want legislation
interfering in that being said wouldn't
line five and part of line six inform
employees in writing of any policy
regarding ACR or use of vacation time
and any limit or acud or use wouldn't
that be I mean that's the basis of this
entire your entire argument what would
be the harm with having that sentence as
a piece of legislation yeah I'm in
agreement with you and maybe that was
representative Schmid's question as well
I I'm I'm not opposed to reinforcing
that the company policy is what uh
drives it uh my focus has been as long
as that is uh retaining the current
situation I don't have an issue with it
but I think ex getting into these other
things where the company policy May
deviate from what's required that's my
point thank you I have a question um
another question for you here in the L
be Vice chairman seaworth thank you Mr
chairman um and I kind of want to follow
up on uh the Chairman's question because
I was on this committee last year I
remember some of the discussions there
was some confusion with people I talked
to and I'm not sure we were ever on the
same page so I'll ask you as you read
this legislation if there is a conflict
between a company policy is written and
the requirements of line 13 through
15 which would take precedence would it
be the company policy or do is this bill
written so that state law would override
any non-compliant company
policy I think that would be an
appropriate question for the Department
of Labor I I would hope that that line
13 would be removed from this
legislation
up no thank you you thank you Mr Vice
chair all right any other uh I see
representative Bui has his hand up
representative buy you're recognized for
a
Ben there you go understand me better
when you can't hear me
maybe um 13 and 14 no
if if I got fired today for whatever
reason I'd have to get paid to by
tomorrow what would be the difference in
that if if I get fired it's probably an
unpleasant
termination and my pay has to be there
the next day why wouldn't my pay plus my
built up vacation time be there the next
day and I I do believe
that if there's written policy such as
what you stated that if you walk off the
job before the jobs finish and it harms
the company that that's in company
policy and if I sign an agreement that
says that I agree to that so I I don't
think that this would override it and I
don't think the the state law would
override a personal
contract it's up to the department to uh
let's just assume that let's just assume
that U your company has a policy that
says You must give a two- week notice if
you're going to leave in order to to get
your vacation time this bill would make
company it would mandate it would
override it and say that you're owed it
circumstances followup followup thank
you yes sometimes especially in a
construction business um you could be
done with a job and not even know it
within two weeks like once the job is
finished you're off the job and you move
on to the next one but I think that
anytime something is earned they should
get it when they're when they leave I
think that's the bottom line thank
you would you believe thank you would
you believe that I I believe that
represent
Bry sorry Ben all right any other
questions yes sir a representative turot
has a question thank you Mr chairman
thank you uh Mr avoc for the question um
looking at line three again uh excuse me
line
five are you aware of any of the
companies that you
represent who offer vacation days that
do not inform their employees of their
vacation policy no I'm I I believe all
the companies inform their employees and
give out office policies uh when they
start employment at the company and then
they also receive it whenever there's a
company update I I believe I'm I'm in
strong belief that all the companies do
that thank
[Music]
you okay I don't see any other questions
in the L or
online thank you for this opportunity
thank you Mr
Abbott next up is David ju from the Bia
proposes the bill David Welcome to the
committee see your name there you
[Music]
are thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I trust you can hear me okay
yes for the record my name is Dave J I'm
a senior vice president at the business
and industry
Association uh we serve as the state of
New Hampshire Statewide Chamber of
Commerce I'm here in opposition to this
bill um many of uh bia's reasons for
opposing the bill were articulated very
well by Gary Abbott I would like to
emphasize based on uh Deputy
Commissioner Ogden's uh reporting of the
numbers uh relating to this type of
situation it strikes me as being a very
low number and he acknowledged that uh
even those numbers which I consider to
be low many of those are because either
the employee misunderstood the employer
policy or just didn't agree with it so I
think we're trying to uh
correct um a problem that does not
happen very often and the way we are
choosing to do it is to again have the
state decide for employers what their
employee benefits should be and as I've
testified on other similar bills we
believe that employers are in the best
position to develop a benefits policy
that allows them to attract and retain
the employees that they uh want and need
for their Enterprises just a couple of
specific other issues um it was alluded
to earlier but I want to emphasize that
many employers across New Hampshire are
moving away from vacation time and
moving away from sick time and calling
it instead personal time that could be
used either when the individual is not
feeling well or when they want to use a
vacation so this bill I'm not sure how
that would treat personal time it's not
mentioned in the language of the bill
and I also wanted to respond to a
question that I think representative
seaworth asked um because he's correct
there are some companies and this
happens uh a lot in the tech sector that
are doing away with vacation in sick
time benefits completely and just
allowing the employee to um take the
time that they want for vacation and
sick time with the understanding that
you know they're still responsible for
for uh job responsibilities over the
long term so for those companies it
would be very confusing how to implement
this bill where it to become law so once
again the Bia is opposed and I'd be
happy to address any questions from the
committee thank you Mr
juv I don't see any questions here oh I
do see one representative turot you
recognize for a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you Mr duvet for taking
the question uh were you online when I
asked Mr AB question question about are
you aware of any companies you represent
that offer the vacation but do not
inform their employees uh I pose the
same question to you yeah thank you
represent turkot well the Bia has uh 400
Plus members they are companies of all
sizes from the state's largest employers
down to single owner operators um I
think our companies uh tend to be
relatively sophisticated employers and I
S I've never
survey them but I suspect most if not
all have some form of of employee uh
manual I know here at the Bia and we're
a small employer we have an employee
manual and on the very first day of
employment uh not only is the manual
distributed but it is gone over uh by by
the HR professional to make sure that
the employee is aware of of uh it has
the opportunity to ask questions about
specific um uh benefits associated with
employment I don't know for for all of
the you know 30 or 40,000 companies here
in New Hampshire how many have employee
manuals but I would suggest that if they
don't they should because obviously that
helps um alleviate any confusion over
what benefits they offer and what
benefits they do not
offer thank you for your answer I didn't
mean you put you on the hook for the
companies any other additional questions
in the
lob any questions on
Zoom seeing none thank you very much Mr
J thank you Mr
chair I'd like to next call Ellen
scarponi from Consolidated
Communications Ellen are you with us
there you
are I am good morning can you hear me
yes we
can wonderful good morning chairman
infantine and committee members thank
you for the opportunity to talk with you
today my name is Ellen scarponi and I
represent Consolidated Communications I
will be very brief we fully understand
and appreciate that employees should get
vacation time that they deserve
Consolidated currently provides for all
of the conditions that are set out in
this bill however we oppose hb13 because
we do not think that voluntary benefits
provided by an employer should be
regulated uh similar to what Mr Abbott
and what Mr ju have said we ask that the
committee find HB 1113 inexpedient to
legislate thank you for your
consideration and I'm happy to answer
any
questions any questions for the
presenter see none in the
lob seeing no hands on
Zoom oh yes I do sorry I apologize for
that representative Tumi you recognized
for a question thank you Mr chairman uh
it seems to me that this policy only
applies to employers that set up a
policy where vacation is acred like once
a month or once every two months or or
or some kind of a policy and what it
seems to me that this uh legislation
deals with employers that do that
employers that have other policies
saying for example you don't get a
vacation unless you work the full 12
months in their policy manual it seems
to me this would not apply to that this
seems to me only to apply to employers
that set a policy that vacation time is
acred uh in a certain way and once they
set that policy it's up to the to the
law to hold them to the policy that they
set uh am I right or am I
wrong thank you for the question
representative if I understand correctly
you're you're asking if a company has
established a policy say in a manual
such as Mr juv was was um citing that uh
their policy supersedes anything else is
that
correct not sure I understand well you
you would this bill says that employ uh
that any they inform employees in
writing of any policy regarding their
vacation time and limits on it um each
situation is different with Employers in
New Hampshire as the Deputy Commissioner
do said uh these things are not
regulated by the state it is employee
specific because vacation time and sick
time and personal time are all
voluntary and so I can speak for
Consolidated we have a very specific
manual as Mr juv said about the Bia that
goes through each and every detail and
an employee must sign that when they
commence employment and if anything
changes during their employment uh their
re these policies are reviewed and so I
I again think that this would try to
regulate something that is individual to
a company and should not be regulated at
a state
level can I answer that question Mr
chairman have a followup yes okay well
it seems to me that if you set policy
and you don't have to set the policy
that vacation acru once a month or once
every two weeks or
whatever if you don't want to live up to
that policy don't set it but once you
set it and the employee reads it and
signs the the policy manual it seems to
me that you have to live up to it and if
you don't live up to it somebody has to
step in and say you're required to live
up to it because you made that agreement
just like any other contract so uh
that's my point Thank you for for your
question though and for your testimony
thank you Mr
chairman thank you representative
Tumi um thank you uh oh
session we have a question from our vice
chairman thank you Mr chairman see worth
your recognize a representative the
previous representative's um question if
you will confus me a little bit I
thought I heard this explained earlier
but I'll ask you um you said your your
company has a policy that addresses the
issues that are within this bill um if I
were an employee of your company and I
felt that you had violated the policy
that you have written and that you've
given to
me am I correct in understanding that I
could take that to the Department of
Labor and they would adjudicate it and
enforce your policy if in fact you were
not following
it thank you thank you for your question
representative I am not certain of the
answer to that and would refer to uh uh
Deputy Commissioner Ogden in the
Department of Labor all right thank
you all right thank you Mr Vice chairman
do I have any other questions in the
L seeing none any
online seeing Oh yes last minute
representative Sullivan you're
recognized for a question I was just
going to point out that I see U Deputy
Commissioner Ogden is present and
capable of answering that last
question thank you representa s I was
gonna ask him if he would be willing to
representative uh uh M get my names
right here assistant Comm Ogden did you
hear the question would you like to
opine I did and apologies I I don't mean
to be presumptuous and speak up so
that's why if you have questions at any
time I'm happy to answer them I just
just don't want to take multiple turns
speaking so um I'm happy to answer any
questions in terms of the last question
uh yes under present law if there was a
a policy that was not being followed uh
that is what would be enforced so uh we
have had instances in which an employer
has a policy um the employer does not
follow the policy the claim is pro
brought forward uh and then we would
make an order for payment uh relative to
the UN the lost time or the time that
should have been uh to the benefit of
the employee uh one other question that
was asked a couple times are there
employers who do not give out policies
yes that does happen I would uh agree
with Mr juve's point that a lot of
sophisticated employers do provide these
policies uh but we certainly come into
contact with employers that do not
provide these policies uh to their
employees thank
you thank you uh Mr Ogden and thank you
uh Miss gpon just making sure before I
let everyone go there's any additional
questions here in the
LLB any
online see none thank
you um I don't know the
opportunity you're very welcome um hey
representative kale I'm not sure if
you're you're uh in charge of the
computer right now or if it's
Christina uh I believe I'm in charge
okay well do we have any last minute uh
individuals who'd like in the Que would
c no go ahead representative kale oh no
that's that's quite all right I didn't
know you were there but I don't see any
hand Judith Spang would like to
representative
Spang thank you uh representative kale
representative Spang you're um
recognized to speak on House
Bill uh oh thank you very much yes um
I've left all the details to everybody
else and I'm going to speak to the
forest rather than the trees from the
first moment that representative kahill
uh talked to me about this bill I I was
100% in favor of it in my mind it is a
matter of fairness it is a matter of
living up to a contracts and I am was
very proud that this committee and that
the house passed this bill in
recognition of of that basic premise and
I think when our workers are in such
trouble in terms of their incomes with
covid uh it is a a vote of confidence
that we give to them that we think that
they should get at least what is due to
them um ethically um so I the the
details I think have been well worked
out last year through the three work
sessions and I'm just going to appeal to
your basic sense of fairness here thank
you very
much thank you
representative do I have any questions
in the L for the representative Spang
online seeing none thank you
representative Spang thank you
representative kahill do we have anyone
else in the
queue uh I I don't see any hands uh I do
see other people attendees but no no one
has raised a hand they're just listening
we are just uh such an interesting
committee they all want to listen in all
right seeing no additional people in the
queue uh I have no additional
individuals who have signed up uh either
to testify or as a position so I'll be
closing the hearing on House Bill 113
have approximately eight minutes before
we have a very very difficult bill just
kidding on House Bill
8589 um I have 12 people in support and
no one wants to talk so it looks like
we're going to have just a sponsor
hopefully present this piece of
legislation I would like a few few
comments while we have a few minutes
here before everyone goes and takes a
quick break about our executive session
this afternoon um I don't know if
everyone's had the opportunity to read
the rules about executive session and
how we'd like to proceed first of all we
have a tremendous amount of um
amendments on some bills which I believe
are going to be pretty unanimous about
how we are going to pass these um but I
need to make sure I have all these
because I have multiple ones Heather are
you um hearing
us by any
chance I'm used to the old fashioned way
you bring me down a nice yellow or red
folder you know and you bring it down to
we have the Amendments and with a little
red tab on it and we have all these
things um I have been sending all of you
every amendment that I have received so
um we're going to have to it might be a
little slow this afternoon we start off
to make sure everyone has the right
amendments and for those any new members
on the lefthand corner um on the
amendment like this one I'm looking at
from representative seaworth is 2021
d2008 so we'll know that's how you know
which amendment um we're we're we're
talking about representative uh Sullivan
raised yes uh
it lots of Amendments have been coming
in uh they've been coming in during a
time period when we we've been getting
flooded with emails um and if we read
the um email with the attached Amendment
at a time when we couldn't print it um
we may have lost track of it um if
someone Heather perhaps um could uh uh
give us a list of the Amendments that we
need to to locate um we can probably I I
can probably find them but um uh it
otherwise we may find ourselves starting
on an exec session and and some of us
don't have the the necessary amendments
what I will try to do representative
Sullivan is uh I think our next hearing
is going to take about 10 minutes I'm
going to study all my amendments here
and see if I can pick out exactly the
bill number and the amendment number for
each one to make sure which one it is so
prior to um our 1:00 executive session I
will read these off so everyone knows
which ones if they can write it down or
uh we'll know which which um amendments
to look at and then uh if there's any
issues um if if anyone does not have
those emails we'll make sure they they
get there in the mean Heather hasn't
chimed in yet but
IA of infantine this is Christina um if
while you're doing that if you want to
send me an email list I can compile them
and send them out again in one email if
that would be helpful that would be
extremely helpful a lot of thumbs up on
that one and and even someone blew you a
kiss I'll take
it kiss Thank You representative Smith
did you ask a question just a moment I
have to recognize representative Smith
first I just I just wanted to know if we
had anybody who was interested who
signed up on this on one side or the
other do you do you have those that
information on the previous Bill yes on
113 there was no one um
only no one
as the people that spoke had signed up
there was no one else who wow went in
well I'm sorry representative infantine
I just gave you the testimony list um if
that were the numbers at the top I can
read to you that there were 16 in
support 10 opposed and one neutral on
each bill each B one oh thank you
Christine I appreciate that put the
numbers on the top of your list chairman
infantine I'm sorry would you repeat on
the testimony list usually it will say
support oppos and neutral was that on
your list or no I guess there it is no
you have it but it's on there in the
color I missed that when I okay thank
you thank you I it's kind of a new
fangled thing here they kind of there's
one little line here at the top it has
the red the green and the neutral we
just changed it because we want we know
you want to know so I I wanted to point
that out always the last ones to know
all right thank you representative uh
ter roian I believe that was you that
asked a
question right thank you Mr chair yes I
had a question um where I'm filling in
if I can get emailed the Amendments
before we start at one o'clock yes I
will make sure the two of you um get
those and then we will be um probably
having you call in uh to talk with us at
noon time during our break and I'll get
back to you on that okay
representative that'd be fine thank
you were the were there any other
questions all right so there's been some
acrimony um going back and forth I guess
someone told me there was a court
session recently on zoom and where the
person was not the person who was
actually the defendant or something and
um so now everyone's worried about who's
voting are they actually the right
person voting is people voting in favor
of you and some of the pictures here
uh there's no pictures there's just a
black um screen that says your name so
the procedure when we vote on Executive
session when the clerk is just going to
call your name and I would appreciate if
you would respond as follows
representative Susi vote Yes
representative Tumi votes no just say
your name and how you vote if that's all
right with everyone just so we have it
all specific if anyone wants to complain
later we have everyone's voice that we
all can recognize so I just I just don't
want any I don't want anyone to ever
question how we do things here in labor
right representative Solan we follow the
rules there you go um I open it up to
any other questions we have a few
minutes here another two minutes any
chair all right thank you you guys want
to take a two two minute three minute uh
bathroom break uh please come back in
two or three minutes thank you very
much
didn't see
that I the only reason I know is I
missed it last week and I was
wondering how people were counting
numers so fast but it was up there
before they put it in color but they
don't leave they don't give us
anymore that's fine whatever it does
make it easier because before we had to
hunt and find the speaking and that was
not
true
[Music]
for
what
back commercial
breaks
[Music]
name okay yes just waiting for a few
people to see their pretty faces so I
know we're here in attendance it is
10:04 we will very
and our double duty representative will
be introducing his bill all right
uh I think we have enough people here
house uh labor committee's back in
session I will open the hearing on House
Bill 589 FN and recognize the sponsor
representative kahill to introduce your
bill thank you Mr chairman uh once again
we're here to talk about uh
uh prophylactic treatment for First
Responders who have had critical
exposure this is House Bill 589
dfn uh we've talked about this for
several years now those of you who have
been Veterans of the committee will
remember this uh there was an issue with
a with language that was
inserted last time with
uh information that the the saliva if
someone spits in your face Cas you have
to determine that there's sufficient
that there's if there's blood in
sufficient magnitude that would cause
illness now this is quite a test if
you're if they spit in your eye I don't
know how you're going to see it and uh
and of course the first thing you're
going to do is wipe it off and what is
sufficient magnitude it's not really
defined it's not practical so we're
striking that language and we're just
going to leave it up to the medical
professional who that you that you
should see following such an exposure uh
we've had two incidents right here in
New Market where uh um an ENT was uh
bringing a someone down the stairs after
a drug overdose after giving him Naran
and the person spit into his eye that
person saw treatment and the bill was
not paid by workers comp uh absorbed by
our town uh a few years later policeman
responded to a domestic abuse case uh
known drug user and he's spit into the
open mouths the officers during a
struggle
so you may you may recall that uh we had
uh a lobbyist uh working for the uh
workers comp provider who you know had
contested this initially and then said
that you know he was done with it we
were fine and that he wasn't going to go
further with it that we had done what we
should be doing and these are few cases
few cases are few and far between but I
think any Cas is is too many um last
year I gave you a letter from my police
chief citing his concern that you know
new New Market has paid for these
treatments and that other smaller towns
may you know the uh first responded may
be nervous about causing an extra
expense for the town and you know
pressures being what they are not get
the treatment they need not be given not
have the Baseline test or given the
treatment that may prevent the disease
from taking root so I hope that this
year once again we will pass it get it
over to the other body who will take it
to the next step and I can stop talking
to you about this issue thank you very
much Mr
chairman thank you
L questions online we
do I see one see one here I couldn't see
onl thank you Mr chairman representative
um am I to understand this is uh to
definition um thank you for the question
what what the bill does is it says that
uh if you have exposure to uh ruptured
skin or or mucous membranes including
the eyes or mouth with
um blood or body fluids including saliva
you should be able you should get
treatment that should be determined by
provider
yes
I G take a just a quick quick Liberty
here representative K if you don't mind
legislation if you look at RSA 28 8182
IE um it does Define critical exposure
that's that's that's what that this part
is amending but yeah I will accept your
follow-up question because the followup
question is
um do you consider the the part of of
your bill where it says um in uh one- e
um testing and treatment shall be
determined by a medical provider taking
into account the physical examination
and incident details provided by the
patient you consider that a
definition
um well yeah the the critical Expos the
the definition is the U the person who
has suffered the exposure would uh seek
treatment and explain to the provider
what has uh transpired
and that the uh the uh provider would
then evaluate that information and exam
and do an exam and determine these steps
that would be taken to prevent injury or
illness
Point uh any other questions in the L
[Music]
any questions
online uh uh this is Will infantine
representative I have two questions for
you number one did this bill just die
because of covid and Omnibus that is
correct my second question is I
understand would you believe I
understand what representative Huff is
saying and that you might want to talk
about this while I'm 100% support of
this bill we may want to take that one
sentence out and put it under another
maybe C1 or something like that because
you are confusing a definition with a an
action would you believe uh I certainly
would Mr chairman and um it's it's a
minor change but a major major
impact any other questions for
representative
kahill I see no hands online I see no
hands in the L thank you very much Mr
kahill representative
kahill I currently
have seven individuals in support zero
oppose one neutral no one else wants to
testify representative kahill or do we
have anyone in the queue with a hand up
that would like to testify I see no
hands pardon me uh representative um Mr
Ogen from the uh Department of Labor uh
did sign up a little bit y you did tell
me that my apologies for not putting it
to memory yes representative Ogden's
going to be busy this morning he wants
to talk about all great representative
Ogden you
representative okay Ogden you are
recognized I appreciate the promotion uh
chairman
and for the record uh Rudy Ogden Deputy
Commissioner Department of Labor um just
in terms of offering thoughts on this I
think it's important to recognize and I
I think representative Huff's question
uh teases this out uh the operative
effect of this adjustment is these
definitional terms of critical exposure
and prophylactic or post-exposure
prophylaxis these are defined terms
under existing law specifically critical
exposure which is being amended is then
called out in the definition of
postexposure prophylactics the important
of those terms the importance of those
terms being called out is that under RSA
a23 6 and 6A there is reference to the
fact about what should happen when there
has been a critical exposure or when
prophylaxis treatment has been called
for and terms of the discussion that
just happened about perhaps that one
portion of the uh adjustment being
pulled out of the definitional section
um I would offer the option of again an
RSA 281
A236 and six paragraph six and paragraph
6A that's actually where the compulsion
is called for that for Force responders
expenses associated with post uh
postexposure prophylactics are to be
paid for so again that would be one area
where if you want to put in that
language associated with who determines
what evaluation and testing should be
done it might be better situated or
might sit better there uh so again I
just think in considering this uh this
bill you should be looking at RSA 281
a23 paragraph 6 and paragraph 6A that's
actually again the operative effect of
what you're doing with these definitions
so I think representative kahill
described what the fix or what the
intent is here but I would recommend
looking at the language in that statute
that I've cited uh and again I would
also offer that that might be an option
for where to put that second part of the
the proposed
Bill uh commissioner aan I'm looking at
a23 right now you said paragraph five
and six A2 five so paragraph five and
six are where in statute is talking
about the provision of care relative to
critical exposure
I think chiefly we're talking about 6A
here which says that all expenses
associated with the medical evaluation
and recommended postexposure prophylaxis
treatment for emergency response SLU
safety workers shall be paid by the
employer's insurance carrier or third
party
administrator um and then it goes on to
say such medical evaluation uh shall be
provided without prejudice to the issue
so I just point out there that that's
the section which says that when a first
responder or safety worker has been ex
had a critical exposure that the
insurance carrier or self-insured entity
is to provide uh for the costs and and
again I think that this might be the
section where you could say when we're
talking about costs or we're talking
about protocols and preventative
measures those should be uh done by the
person making uh the initial uh looking
incident Mr chairman
representative kale you have a question
for mren or do you want to speak again
or well I'm thinking that the the reason
that this was put here was because of
the other language that that said that
the uh the must be visible blood in
sufficient
magnitude and that's kind of what I was
trying to address why it was placed
there uh I want to make sure that that
that isn't that part is uh removed so
that
uh I think I think we're only talking
about the term the words testing and
treatment shall be determined by the
medical provider is that what you
understand that we're
discussing uh okay well you said your
definition of critical exposure which
you know
I'm it is my is my belief that critical
exposure
definition through the words person's
bodily or blood or bodily fluids should
be under RSA a21 e where it is correct
currently and that the the sentence
testing and treatment shall be
determined by the medical
provider um and incidental details
provided by the patient should go under
A236 as Mr Ogden has outlined I you know
I'm trying to do the best I can here
trying to read it as I'm going here um
but it does talk about the expenses
associated with it and that would
probably be the place to to add that is
that um
your am I do I understand you correct
commissioner Ogden uh correct apologies
if I wasn't clear what I was speaking to
is exactly what you've just described
namely where representative Huff had
pointed out that second sentence perhaps
not fitting neatly within a definitional
section okay we're good thank you yeah
if you have an opportunity to go on to
um 281 a20 three five and six there and
take a look at that it might
be I don't know I'm just lucky I can I'm
reading it right here so I can see it
okay thank you uh commissioner Ogden any
other questions for
either representative kahill or
commissioner Ogden in the
L I see none
online I also see
none representative kahill we have
anyone in the queue I see no one no
hands okay unless I see anything further
as I said we have seven support zero
oppos one neutral no one want wishing to
testify that being said I'm going to
close the hearing on House Bill
589 and if you wouldn't mind folks
taking a break until quarter of 11
before we have our next hearing and then
hopefully I will have determined all of
the correct amendments and dealt with uh
Christina and try to get those emailed
to everyone so we know what we're
dealing with I might be calling on
individual any some of you just in case
you are the the the sponsors of some of
these amendments so um I'll try to catch
you online if I'm I'm sure any questions
of the
chair yes representative AG thank you Mr
chairman I uh didn't get a schedule um
could I just get a refresher which goes
second yes you will yes you may I'll
shortly all right we're in recess till
uh 10:45 thanks everyone all right let
me
gets
A236
[Music]
for
representative infantine could you get
someone to unmute the computer in the
room please we can't hear you so
whenever you're
great wonderful thank you so much
we didn't want you to know what we were
saying I'm not sure I wanted to know
either discuss presence
for we're talking about Len flying is
747 over the Atlantic 780
787 um folks um I'm still trying to work
um
we lost the audio we lost the
audio conversations because she had to
um go to Target and get some ink for her
computer so um I'm going to have the
other Hearing in in 13 minutes and
hopefully I can get through the
remainder of these amendments to make
sure we have the right ones and the
right
procedure uh representative Sullivan has
your caucus told you anything about
you know you know the oldfashioned way
we have the we have the
folders and we have to sign off on these
things and we have to do the blurbs and
we have to um you know make sure we have
the red taged
amendments um you know the fact that we
can't walk over to
L and back and forth did they give you
any direction because I'm still waiting
for additional
Direction not really um the I I know
last uh last session um
they uh I believe took the red tags off
of the Amendments so I I believe that
piece is gone um the um because I and
and I because it was before my time I
don't really even recall how that worked
but I think it it was simplified last
year for the amending process um so I
don't I don't think we need to have an
official copy of an amendment um they're
all
um it's okay to print them right off the
computer Heather did uh before she had
to go uh to get more Inc uh did put
together all of the updated amendments
she has so as um I'll be just going
through this next couple minutes and
I'll get an email to Christina uh just
to make sure that um we have all of them
um so I apologize I was hoping to do
this right now guys but I need a couple
more minutes one thing I do want to
point out I sent around an email and I
want everyone to make sure that they
received um House Bill 590 FN we had a
new fiscal impact that was provided to
us 24 hours ago and I sent that to
everyone's email in case you it got
caught and lost amongst all the other
emails you might just want to look at
that one that was the only updated
Financial U note fiscal note that we
received just wanted to make sure you
that and with that unless there's any
questions I'm going to go Corral with a
couple of these guys make sure we have
all the the correct amendments any
me
um representative T
us
yeah I'm with you thank you are you able
to do you have a camera that allows us
to see you by any chance on your
computer I can see
him
yeah not not representative to me oh
toosi I'm
[Music]
sorry uh let's see I don't see
representative ter roian at the moment
let me take a
look yeah I don't see him either
okay because I I I believe we have to
see everyone's pretty faces when they
vote I believe he was on the phone he
was and I will reach out to him um and
see where he's at and if he plans to
come I don't I didn't see representative
Melvin but he may show up for the
afternoon only yeah so representative K
you can't wear any funny masks or
anything for any any any George Clooney
masks or anything
right all right guys uh we'll be back on
in about nine minutes um Brian Len if I
could talk to you guys some of these
ones
have well I have some I print them all
out because I'm a goof so 258 okay
records require this is the one where um
Rudy Ogden yes said it was
[Music]
um sorry I want to move your your
helped
yeah um
so this is the this is
the I I want to make sure I have the
right numbers I'm talking about policy
yeah okay I believe this is the one
Brian okay now
259 um this is the uniform bill this is
the one I have the only one I
have I don't think there were any
additional
changes Brian 301 this is the one that
you and
Ben yeah so that should be 296 right
yeah yeah 296
different so this one is out right that
okay 303 Brian I believe this is yours
that should be 189
yeah 348 oh okay that's I going back and
thank
385 FN this is the one that changed it
[Music]
Christina are you um online uh yes I am
all right I'd like to go over to make
sure I have the correct um
168h okay House Bill
91h
okay
301 House Bill 301 296 H okay House Bill
303 189
H
okay
47h okay
have and you said uh I'm sorry what was
385 385 is three
07h
07 okay I will uh make sure we have
youcome
drink I got a from know me basically
train
train Captain we've got
a
whatever neighbors came over and um
enjoy the day off they take so having a
race out of
[Music]
here that I needed
it gez you get buzzed and then you're
wired I hated you know I hated the feel
but I know some people that live off
hour
but
yeah of course some my kids play sports
I know a couple edits that Judy
to she was it about a year ago someone
consistent
every time I had the word deocr she
deal yeah everybody's like oh why don't
noted the only only I ever drank were
like
like 40% sugar cream like they put like
aino basically in bag and that was they
were good they weren't I had friends in
college you know they had to stay up and
study all night so they wanted caffeine
so someone had
[Music]
at see
that so I think it was M of the military
lost
wet3
interesting
interviewing you handsome back then
old chairman infantine I checked all of
the the numbers I do have the correct
amendments I know Heather sent them out
momentarily in separate emails um did
you want me to put them all in one email
yes please okay I'll do that now zip it
zip for
it I'm sorry representative
biry oh he's talking to the
dog yeah I'm sorry that's okay we got
Clarance
cockp it's under a certain amount of
hours only two of us like canun it's
only two
we were going over to Europe the D3 if
asia4
[Music]
ready thank you welcome back everyone it
is now 11 am. and I am always late so
the fact that I'm on time is
awesome we are going
to open our hearing on
our final Bill
maybe um House Bill 261 relative to
Apprentice programs in trade and
Industry and I recognize our sponsor
representative Brian seaworth who for
this hearing will not be Vice chairman
of the
committee thank you Mr chairman I'll
virtually step away from the committee
table here so I can introduce House Bill
261 for the record my name is
representative Brian seaworth I
represent Penbrook and
shester um this is another bill the
third and final you'll be happy to hear
bill that I submitted um that kind of
came through the study committee that I
talked about to sessions ago um this is
language that came to us from the
Department of Labor as a as a requested
update um like the last one I presented
this particular RSA was outside the
scope of that study committee so the
study committee took no action and made
no opinion on it um however we had uh
this language and so when we came to a
new session this year I
submitted um the request exactly as the
Department of Labor had written it uh I
turned it into OS and it is now now HB
261 um compared to the other two bills
that I've presented to the committee
this is obviously uh has a bit more to
it um it's a bit more
complicated and I am probably not the
one to go through the details with you
so what I am going to do is ask Deputy
Commissioner commissioner Ogden to
explain the det details of this bill and
I would suggest that committee members
reserve the tough questions for him
because he will be able to answer it um
but the point of this bill like the
other two is it's intended to be a
housekeeping bill and the intention is
that uh
the federal labor law on the uh
surrounding the issue of apprenticeship
has changed and the department would
like to get our state labor law aligned
with that and this bill is should be
doing no more and no less than that so
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
the committee any questions for
lobb any questions online on
Zoom seeing none the chairman has a
question representative I received a
relatively tur email last night on this
bill uh saying how you were ruining
everything and doing everything terrible
and this looks like just some word
smithing um on updates was
that is there your opinion that possibly
have you seen that email number
one thank you Mr chairman yes I believe
I saw that email and I'll ask for a
followup I give myself a followup and um
you think it was just misunderstood
thank you Mr chairman um I do believe
that it was a misunderstanding certainly
it misunderstands my
intent I did not put any I didn't have I
took the input directly from the
Department of Labor and turned that over
to
OS um this is not a request for any
policy changes I certainly had no input
in in terms of policy that I tried to
get in here uh as far as the
details you know the consequences of the
language changes are probably a little
bit
over what I'm capable of answering so I
certainly encourage any members who have
concerns about the
language um to ask the Department of
Labor to clarify things all right I'm
just going to cut right to it if that's
okay because um there's concerns that Mr
Ogden can um Can clarify but just for
any other questions here in the
lb I'm seeing none any questions
online seeing none commissioner Ogden
are you with us yes thank you chairman
infantine and thank you representative
seaworth for bringing for this forth
this bill um as representative seaworth
indicated the this bill is something
that the department actually did come
forward with specifically commissioner
marifield who had been in discussions
with uh Lauren Smith from the federal uh
us office of apprenticeship this is
something that had been talked about
between the Federal Department of Labor
and the New Hampshire Department of
Labor a as an item that we should seek
to clean up in terms of specifics or
what the intent is here uh really the
Genesis of this goes all the way back to
2007 in in 2007 RSA 2 78 was amended the
intent of those amendments were to
clarify and make clear that registered
apprenticeship in the state of New
Hampshire would be federally uh
regulated and federally overseen and
what I mean by that is if an employer or
if a trade group or if anything of that
nature is looking to get a registered
apprenticeship program uh if they're
looking to seek uh Federal approve if
they're looking to seek Department of
labor approval if they're looking to
receive grants if they're looking to
receive uh things of that nature that is
all done and funnel through the OA or
the office of apprenticeship at the
federal level uh what is in place
presently is essentially an
apprenticeship advisory Council that is
the council that you if you look at the
language of RSA 278 it's talking about a
council it's talking about what the
council should be doing or is supposed
to be doing
and what I will say is since 2007 and
certainly since I've been in the with
the Department of Labor since
2013 uh the the council has not really
been acting in accord with statute
specifically where it talks in RSA
278 about the council approving or
setting standards all of that has been
happening through the federal usdol
office of apprenticeship so that's
really the Crux of what we're trying to
do here
uh I believe there is a lot of confusion
around this uh area I've spoken to two
individuals from Trad unions this week
and after speaking with them I don't
mean to speak for them and maybe they'll
be speaking today but they seem to
understand what was happening and had no
concerns I will say I spoke with one
gentleman who said something similar to
I believe that tur email which is
essentially you know these are all
registered programs and you're going to
get rid of all these programs that's not
what we're looking to do what we're
looking to have happen is just have a
statute which better reflects the
reality which is that this registration
these approvals and the standard setting
does not happen at this Council it
happens at the office of apprenticeship
and again I would go back to 2007 in
2007 the US Department of Labor when
they saw what was happening with RSA 278
they essentially made the request of us
to serve as an advisory Council they did
not want this Council uh setting
standards because again they believe
that registration approval and standard
setting resides with them the only other
thing I would point out is if folks have
concerns with what this statute uh what
the statutory amendment is seeking to do
it is something that should be talked
about because again this council is not
doing certain of the things where you
see strikeouts in this bill specifically
around if you look in paragraph three
where we talk about striking out
supervision of the execution of
agreement and mainten of Standards if
you talk about paragraph five this
Council issuing certificates uh that's
stuff that this council is not doing um
so lest anyone say that we are changing
anything in practice this will change
nothing it will just be that the council
will now truly sit as an advisory
Council which is our understanding was
the intent going back to 2007 um again
we believe in apprenticeship we believe
in the fact that there are a number of
individuals who have made wonderful
careers by through for themselves going
through apprenticeship and it's a
wonderful powerful tool that helps a lot
of people and does a lot of good this is
not in any way seeking to undermine that
again what's happening now is all of
this is happening through the office of
apprenticeship through the USD and we
just want to make clear that that is the
track in which to pursue registered
apprenticeship again I'm not trying to
speak for the usdol but I can
comfortably say that they have had some
concerns that with the existing law it
appears is that there are these two
tracks to registered apprenticeship one
through this Council one through the
office of apprenticeship and we just
want to clarify that there is one track
and it's through the office of
apprenticeship with the usdol not
through this apprenticeship advisory
you okay thank you
commissioner Ogden I have any questions
of any of the committee members online
representative Sullivan and then
representative
buard can't hear you
representative there it goes sorry
um Deputy Commissioner and actually the
Mr chairman as well you you mentioned a
tur email um I don't believe that went
to the entire committee did it and if so
uh uh give me a second the vice chairman
is going to I thought it was sent around
to everybody I assumed it came to my
email that I get when you send uh an
members Brian's gonna I'm I'm just I
guess I'm curious um who the individual
was who is all up in arms about the um
about this bill
is he some official or is he member of
the public I'm G to get that for you it
was I I may answer as nonmember of the
committee um we received an email on
February 9th at in the afternoon mine is
time stamp
312 um signed by Michael Smith business
business agent Iron Workers Local 7even
with some strong opposition to this bill
and I believe that was the one don't
think I saw it
either and just to clarify I did not
receive an email I spoke with two
individuals over the phone thank you
repres uh thank you commissioner a
representative Sullivan did you hear
that information from from Brian I I I
did and um
followup no I I'll look it up I I'll
look up the email thank you okay um
again I'm not trying to um uh disparage
the gentleman he it was not foul it was
not rude it was not any of those things
it was um uh very definite that you're
doing significant harm and and that kind
of came of a surprise to me so I'm not I
don't want to insinuate in any way shape
or form that um he was an appropriate
all right I did we all got it it came to
the entire committee 312 on Tuesday
thank you representative Warden I have a
I have a question from representative
bushard followed by Bui and Tumi
representative bushard
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh assistant uh Deputy Commissioner um I
also got that email and I was concerned
to see if you can reinforce that this
bill will ensure that workers are well
trained as well as performing their work
safely uh thank you representative buard
again I would just the those standards
that are set set forth relative to
training and those standards that are
set forth relative to safety for these
apprenticeship programs those are all
put forth and promulgated by the office
of apprenticeship uh so again I do not
see this statutory change as in any way
impacting the training or safety
afforded to individuals seeking out
apprenticeships again I think what we're
trying to do is clarify the fact that
this Council which meets I believe on a
quarterly basis this Council does not
discuss those things and this Council
does not promulgate those things uh this
Council literally the times I've been
there uh they they talk about
opportunities they talk about events
they talk about uh opportunities to seek
out new uh venues for apprenticeship
programs but this Council in and of
itself does not discuss or Define what
should be done in terms of training or
safety for apprenticeship programs that
all sits with the office of
thank
you uh representative uh barudi and then
Tumi I'm all set Mr chairman I had a
question for you before but interrupt
the testimony thank you representative
Tumi yeah uh thank you uh Mr chairman I
I must have missed something I had no
idea this was coming up today uh are we
executing on this today or or this no
represent T this is just our last Bill
to be heard in in in committee will not
be exeed at all okay thank you um I
don't think it's going to be exec till
at least March 4th when will probably be
our next uh labor committee meeting okay
thanks a lot appreciate it any questions
um any additional questions
online I don't see any any additional
any questions of
um um in the
lb I don't see any representative Broody
you said you had a question for me is it
relative to this Bill you're feel free
inquire thank you Mr chairman no you
were talking about the email and I was
just going to ask if uh that person was
going to testify today don't know we'll
find out in a moment I have no other
people on my list but I'm sure now uh
representative kahill and Christina will
tell me if there's anyone else in the
you I don't see any hands raised Mr
chairman
up okay got one now Lauren Smith it
looks like someone just popped on
representative kill welcome Lauren
Smith I just wanted to let you know I am
the state director for the State of New
Hampshire for the US Department of Labor
office of apprenticeship and I'm happy
questions I'm sorry you're the uh new
have representative to the new Hamp
United States
do yes sir I am okay this is just uh
this is just will infant timee any
questions do anyone have anything uh for
for Miss Smith any questions about the
bill specifically yes representative
Tumi you're recognized for a question um
yeah thank you uh Mr Mr chairman uh now
you know I haven't really had a chance
to to take a look at this but I was
concerned about this this
bill uh because I'm concerned whether
this takes away some of the unions
involvement and Power in in terms of
apprenticeship programs and turns it
over to the solely to management without
uh any kind of uh
guarantee that the that the unions have
equal
access uh to uh the apprenticeship
programs and and the design of the
apprenticeship programs and the you
know and the design of the apprentiship
programs could Miss Smith help me with
this sure let me give you just a short
history in up until 2007 the state of
New Hampshire assumed the role of all of
the responsibility for all
apprenticeships in New Hampshire in
2007 um they handed it back to the
federal government um and I don't know
the exact reason for that however I do
have documentation saying that they no
longer wanted the responsibility of the
registrations the reviews that type of
thing so um in 2007 the role of the
committee became more um to advise us
about things that were going on in the
state and how we could respond best to
meet the needs State um so what has
happened is the committee has um assumed
that role we have assumed all the roles
of the registration of
programs um and we have two in our
office who continue to register programs
we continue to have grants in New
Hampshire right now we are dealing with
seven grants um that are actually
operated by
um entities some are private some are
public um and all this really this Bill
is saying is that we want to clarify the
language for people who are trying to
explore apprenticeship that the council
is not where they go first um they would
come to our office first because we are
the ones who can do it in the past
people had to wait a month or so for the
meeting of the council in order to be
approved for apprenticeship we can
approve apprenticeship in a day if we
need to so as far as your question with
regard to unions nothing has changed
since 2007 it remains exactly the same
unions are a very high priority for us
um as the office of apprenticeship
because obviously that is where
apprenticeship began it is the
foundation of apprenticeship programs we
are expanding into other um areas
besides construction such as Healthcare
it um
manufacturing energy others like that
but as far as the unions nothing has
changed everything will be exactly the
same as it always has been so the safety
is the primary responsibility of the
Secretary of Labor um and that is the US
Secretary of Labor our office reports
directly to the Secretary of Labor in
Washington
DC so I hope I've answered your question
and given you a little bit of the
context that's helpful in understanding
what's happening
here thank you uh for your answer
I am a a little disappointed
that I had no idea this was coming up
today because I would have liked to done
some research on it my daughter is the
commissioner of Labor in Oregon and told
me to watch out for bills dealing with
apprenticeships because of the fact that
in a number of states uh unions are are
being cut out o of the equation and I
would hope that would not happen here in
New Hampshire
so I can't I'm not knowledgeable enough
with about this bill to be able to say
good bad or indifferent so anyway thank
you representative Tumi I'd be happy to
talk to you about that because I know
where that line of thinking is coming
from um so I would be able to talk to
you offline about that but just to give
you a hint of what that's about is
apprenticeship has now adopted in
addition to the registered
apprenticeship program
there is another um type of
apprenticeship that is run by industry
specifically it is called industry
recognized apprenticeship programs and
many unions feel um because they are not
part of that type of apprenticeship that
they are being left out so that's sort
of in a nutshell but it is sort of a
long political discussion about this
additional type of apprenticeship it was
okay thank you and yeah I would like to
y representative Tumi I'm sorry it was
in the calendar I'm sorry you missed it
um as as I said from a from a standpoint
of um our schedule we will be
[Music]
um
meeting next next week not next no I
apologize we will not be meeting again
after today until probably Thursday the
4th of March we were not meeting next
week we are not meeting the week of the
house session which is supposed to be
the 23rd or 24th and 25th of February so
we'll be probably meeting after that we
have to
um probably have another hearing on uh
the representative kahill's amendment to
one of his bills because it's so
different um that I think it it should
have um and uh then we will have an
executive session then so there's you
know a good two or three weeks for
anyone who has any concerns about this
to bring them to my attention or to your
fellow caucus members um and
um hopefully to be to be worked out to
hopefully this is as benign as as it is
being represented to us um
any you're welcome any any additional
Zoom any questions for the members here
in the committee room lb seeing none
representative kahill are there any
additional individuals in the queue yes
Mr chairman we have a David
peler okay Mr peler you recognized to
speak good morning uh chairman infantine
and members of the committee I apologize
I was I wasn't planning on speaking but
I planned on um signing up earlier today
in support and I got caught up uh I did
speak um I represent the um plumbers and
pipe fitters here in um books at New
Hampshire local
131 I did speak to representative
seaworth about the bill as well as um
Deputy Commissioner
Ogden uh as well as I reached out to the
US Department of Labor um with concerns
about striking language and so forth and
so on and you know after talking to
everyone I believe that this bill is is
what it is intended is strictly a house
cleaning item um clears up that
apprenticeship I run through the U
through the US Department of Labor bu of
Apprenticeship Training and I hope you
will support
it thank you Mr peler are there any
questions in the L for Mr
peler any questions online did I see a
hand
anyone I did not thank you Mr fer thank
you represent kill any additional
speakers in the queue Mr chairman there
are no further raised
hands all right see no other uh
individuals willing wishing to speak or
any questions on this bill I will close
the hearing on house Bill
261 and I if I could make some
announcements uh to my committee members
um if if I may uh there were two in
bill so in the record thank
you
um Christina will be sending the
following list of amendments to everyone
bya email if it's not already been done
I will read them in order if anyone
wants to bother to write them down um no
not necessary but just in case you would
259 191
h
amendment to House Bill
H amendment to House Bill
47h House Bill 385
FN
307 and that is all that I have right
now that'll be emailed to
you repat the last one yes House Bill
385 FN
[Music]
toosan is representative ter roian with
us I don't see him he is he just is M
currently hi can you hear me yes I can
representative ter Roan does your
computer have the ability to uh have a
video as we were acquired to your pretty
face uh during no I yep I understand an
email to that and I would it be there or
Pro probably I'll zoom in but yes all
right I'm going to give problem I'm
going to give you your give you my cell
phone number I'd appreciate if you would
give us a call at 11:4 give me a call
11:45 so we can go over all the all the
bills that's what I had planned to do in
fact they had written down your number
is it 622
3325 that's my home I'll give you my
cell phone number everybody else okay
it's uh
9 493
9779 that's correct and if you would
wouldn't mind giving me uh giving me a
call at 11:45 I would appreciate it
we'll do thank you all right and um just
so everyone knows legally um we did it
by the book here we have two members
unable to join us uh Andrew Prout and uh
Leno avalani representative Charles
Melvin is replacing Mr representative
avalan
representative toosan is rep is
replacing representative Prout for the
executive session do we have any uh any
Replacements
um
um see representative Sullivan do we
have any Replacements
um I expect that Linda D sylvestro will
be with us so we I do not need any
Replacements um the um I also wanted to
um uh suggest to uh our caucus we were
going to do a caucus at uh :30 um
perhaps we should do ours at 11:45 as
well so that uh if anybody wants to jump
on to the governor's um budget
presentation they they'll be able to do
that so um without objection I'm going
to change our caucus Zoom caucus to
11:45 um also I want to thank the chair
and uh Christina for getting those um
amendments together I think uh you
probably saved us a great deal of
chaos all right thank you are you guys
going to do your own caucus in a
different Zoom meeting is that we are
okay just wanted to make sure we're on
the same page yep um and uh I just have
one comment since he's here
representative Warden would you like us
telephone you're all set from the other
night oh yeah I'm good okay so you're
going to be basically making all the
correct all right any other questions to
the chair uh before you go
representative infantine um are you when
you're doing your caucus are you going
to be leaving the room or are you going
to be in the room we're going to be in
the room we're going to politely ask
Joshua uh Aden if you wouldn't mind
leaving us and then we're gonna uh mute
the uh this the system okay I'm also
gonna um turn the video off and um so
you'll just have to turn that back on
when you um come back that's and and Dem
Democrats you need to sign out of this
Zoom so you can sign into another one
and then uh at 1:00 we can simply um all
sign back into this uh this Zoom so um
but we need to get get out to get
[Music]
in all right representative S I will be
giving you a call um before we meet at
one o'clock just for um few procedural
things if that's all right I'll call you
great all right thank you repres Selvin
thank you everyone we'll see you at 1
one o'clock in the afternoon thank
you
for
thank
events
boat
for
over
[Music]
okay we're going about to start I'd
appreciate if uh folks uh who are here
would start their videos as we're going
to
be making Vote or you can do it when you
vote that's fine SAR you do it the whole
time if you don't want
to opening executive session it is
101 open the executive session the labor
committee first bill uh in front of us
is House Bill
258 representative Huff calling you for
a
motion thank you Mr chairman
um this bill uh helps to clarify
existing law I'm sorry um I motion I
move to uh that house bill 258 ought to
pass with Amendment Jay you're um
recognized to speak on your motion and
introduce your Amendment and move your
Amendment excuse
me um this bill will help to clarify
move and read the
amendment and I'll second I'll second
this sorry guys um guys just alerted
here first time so we have a a motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 258 It Is
seconded by representative
seaworth you recognize to speak and
introduce your motion or move your
motion excuse me move your Amendment and
I U move to amend HP
258 with
H this bill helps to clarify
already existing
law okay of office
um
mov uh has made a motion not to pass on
258 and is moved Amendment
H I recognize anyone like to speak on
the
bill anyone here in committee no one in
the L
do we have
anyone
on on Zoom you would like to speak on
this
motion we have to make well they will
speak on either either the the original
amendment sorry guys I'm a little
rusty um seeing
none we have a
motion we have an amendment uh we have a
motion off to pass with an amendment we
have a seconded we must make a first
vote on the amendment and do you need a
second on that Amendment if so I'll
second
amendment Brian uh representative
seaworth is
seconding the motion on the
amendment any
questions seeing none Mr clerk would you
please call the role folks if you again
uh when your name is called give your
name and your vote yay for a to pass on
the amendment or
nay
yes Callum repres Callum
yes
K
nunz
yes Warden Warden votes yes on the
amendment
turot turot votes
yes Bo
yes
Melvin
yes ter roian representative Terian
votes
yes h
yes Sullivan Sullivan votes
yes
Susi representative Susi votes yes Rudy
representative buuy votes
yes
kill kill votes yes and compliments
beard
Tumi Tumi votes
yes
Bard representative buard votes
yes ad vot yes chairman infen
time uh represent inen time votes yes
vote is 20 to Zer I I request
uh on the consent
[Music]
agenda oh sorry too fast the amendment
has passed now vote on the bill on the
please uh seaworth seaworth votes
yes Callum
Callum votes
yes Mackie votes yes Nunes Nunes votes
yes
onpa Warden Warden votes yes turot turot
votes yes Lloyd lyd votes yes Huff Huff
votes yes Melvin vot
yes toosan toosan votes yes
Sullivan Sullivan votes yes Susi Susi
votes yes pery Rudy votes yes kahill
kahill votes yes D sylvestro sylvestro
votes yes Schmidt Schmidt votes yes Tumi
Tumi votes yes buard buard votes yes
adant vot
infantine representative infantine votes
yes vote is 20 to
zero thank you um any objection to the
Cent
agenda seeing none thank
you like next uh open the executive
session on House Bill
259 and recognize representative Macky
motion9
itl we have a a
second second seconded by representative
Huff representative Macky you are
recognized to speak on your motion um I
believe this bill is um unnecessary
there was an amendment that was
presented to
um uh fix it but I think the amendment
really doesn't accomplished much and it
really maybe made it even less clear as
recognize anyone else who would like to
LLB seeing none looking for anyone
online I representative Sullivan has
raised his hand you recognize his PE
very simply representative Sullivan
agrees with representative
Mackie thank you representative Sullivan
any other
comments the chair will say that it was
brought to my attention that the bill
may have been more harmed the way it has
been amended because it says I think Ben
representative berui brought this to my
attention it says between zero and three
uniforms which could mean
zero um and uh based the situation we're
in um not having a lot of time and to
deal with a lot of these amendments and
whatever uh we I did
make contact and explain to explain to
the um representative but I did not um
get in touch with him we never spoke so
um it might be good for another day
um seeing no other
hands the motion on the floor is uh in
expedience to legislate by
representative Mackey seconded by
representative um
seaworth H I'm
sorry I thought it was you Brian sorry I
got Brian on The Brak uh Mr clerk you
call the role apologize of
Representative infantine uh did you take
a vote on the
amendment since it's a negative motion
of a to of um itl do you have to I don't
believe you do okay just checking I
apologize anybody parliamentary
procedure I see a lot of shaking heads
no I got that one right yes okay all
right thank you
folks call
call uh seaworth seaworth votes
yes Callum Callum votes yes Macky yes
Nunes n votes
yes bon bon votes
yes turkot turkot votes
yes lyd vot yes Huff Huff votes yes
Melvin vot
yes sosian ter Roan vote Yes Sullivan
Sullivan votes
yes Susi Susi votes yes Peri
Rudy votes yes K Hill kill votes yes t
sylvestro g sylvestro votes yes schmi
SMI votes yes Tumi Tumi votes yes Bard
Bard votes
yes votes yes
yes V is 20 to zero any objection to the
consent
agenda seeing none we'll place it on the
agenda next uh bill in ex executive
session is House Bill 301 relative to
compensation appeals board I recognize
representative Brian seaworth for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move on
to pass and I have an
amendment second second second by
representative turkot uh you recognized
represent Seward to speak on the bill
and and um your Amendment please inter
please move your amendment I would like
0296 H does everyone have
that he your um recognize speaking your
apologize uh I have a second on the
amendment representa turkot seconds the
amendment thank you Mr chairman um first
of all if there was any confusion I I
sent out a earlier version of this
amendment um a little more than a week
ago and then you should have gotten the
newer one within the last either no you
got it today um
this last
Amendment um it combines two different
thoughts uh this is the bill that is
housekeeping in nature and it clarifies
that the members of the workers
compensation appeals board can be paid
either per DM which is currently allowed
in law or hourly uh which is currently
done by
practice um at the suggestions brought
up during the public hearing uh the
amendment was added that the per Dums
are pro-rated on an hourly basis using
7.5 hours per day which once again is
the current practice so it doesn't
change anything it just makes it very
clear in the law what we're doing um if
you recall from the public hearing this
is a request made by the Department of
Labor which in turn is a response to the
LBA audit which said that it would uh be
better from a control standpoint if
their practice were clearly specified in
law the last change that makes today's
Amendment different from the one um that
I sent around a week ago is
representative barudi and I had some
discussions uh based on his
conversations members of the appeals
board and the language as proposed was a
little unclear um we had talked about
hearings being per DM but there are
other things that might be done per dium
such as training such as meetings with
the
commissioner and after discussion all
around uh we agreed and the department
also supported this that changing that
leaving the language as it is saying the
work of the board uh shall be
reimbursed was the best way to specify
and make sure we didn't mess with
current
practice thank you representative
seaworth have any other comments
representative buuy you
recognize thank you Mr chairman um I
think that the language um this
amendment covers what the LBA wanted to
do um specify the seven and a half hours
that gives a more
clearer Distinction on what the rate
will be and for how long at their rate
this is two different rates is a 400 and
a 250 but the S and a half hours uh
makes it clear and I think that's what
the LBA wanted and um just want to thank
representative seaworth for a wonderful
Pleasant working experience working on
this with
them thank you represent buy any other
Representatives wishing to speak on
Zoom any representatives in lob wishing
to speak on this Bill thank you two
gentlemen for working together on this
we have a motion um and a a u and moved
an amendment uh the first vote will be
on on the
amendment if you are in favor of the
member you vote yay if not you vote nay
Mr Clark let's call the r seaworth
seaworth votes yes Callum Callum votes
yes Warden Warden votes
yes uh turot
tur votes yes Boyd boy votes yes Huff
yes
yes Sullivan Sullivan votes yes Susi sui
votes yes buudy Peri vote Yes K Hill
kill votes yes sylvestro he sylvestro
votes yes Schmid Schmid votes yes Tumi
Tumi votes yes Bard Bard votes
yes represent votes
yes 20 to
zero I'd like to um unless
without AC we have to do the that's
right sorry going too fast myself br's
going too fast now we have uh motion on
ought to pass with Amendment vote in
favor of that vote yay if against vote
nay any other comment
uh anyone would like to speak on the
bill was an amendment which is
appropriate right
now Susi all just a point of order who
was the uh
who made the motion who was the second
please on both the bill and the um
Amendment it was seaworth followed by
seconded by turkot thank you very much
welcome seeing no other hands or any
comments either in the L or
online who call rooll uh seaworth
seaworth votes yes car votes yes AI
votes yes Nunes Nunes votes yes Warden
won votes
yes
turot turot votes
yes voyd votes yes Huff Huff votes yes
noelvin vot
yes rosian rosan votes
yes Sullivan votes
yes juy votes yes Peri Peri votes yes
Gill aill votes yes d sylvestro d
sylvestro votes yes Schmidt Schmid votes
yes Tumi Tumi votes yes Bard rard votes
yes vot yes infantine infantine votes
yes 20 to zero okay 20 to
zero without objection i' like to put
this on the consent
agenda thank you for all the thumbs up
see all the cool things we can do on
Zoom you're doing a wonderful job Mr
chairman so
far yeah you may not you may not like
some of my votes further on
representative Broody but we got a good
start I was going to say maybe we should
stop
now but while over ahead
all right uh House Bill 303 relative to
required pay I uh recognize
representative seaworth for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I move on
to pass and I have an
amendment
um
um I yeah okay second by representative
Huff you are recognized to speak and
move your motion thank you Mr chairman I
189h
um everyone has
that uh if you recall from my testimony
this is another housekeeping bill it
takes existing
language
um in the RSA that is
confusing and it separates it clearly
into two cases one that applies to
Municipal and County
workers and then another distinct piece
of language that applies to ski
andboard instructional
employees um the amendment then in the
original draft that word instructional
was left out which could have been
construed to change the intent of the
existing RS say and that's not what
anybody wanted um so the
amendment simply reinserts that term
instructional uh exactly as it is in the
struck thank you I just want to make
sure I've done everything correctly here
uh the motion was made by you on your
your original bill with representative
Huff as a second and then this is your
motion to move your yes Amendment and
representative Huff do you second that
we do we have no that's all right I just
want to make sure I'm doing anything
right here um representative kahill
you're recognized thank you Mr chairman
and uh I just wanted to make sure that
this is a housekeeping Bill and I'm I'm
glad that you put the word instructional
in there so that we don't go downhill
passes good point I I'd like to speak
speak if I if I could for some of you
new new people people like Mr kahill and
representative kahill and some of us
guys who' been in this committee for 10
years um I remember when this came to
fruition as as many of you know or if
you haven't uh if you are an employee
and you are called into work you and
there is no work for you to do you must
be paid for at least a minimum of two
hours work and uh a few years ago I
don't know six eight years ago it was
decided that a lot of these people that
work at the ski areas that teach uh
skiing or snowboarding um would rather
instead of having pay they would rather
go out and ski that's what they like to
do um so it allows them to do this there
was some concern that you know we we
going to start doing this with everybody
that there's no work at the restaurant
so you can have a free meal and going to
do this and how it's going to go and it
really hasn't metastasized into anything
like that that I can see over the last
number of years uh this is a very unique
situation and and although we don't like
to carve a lot of things out as you know
we have a lot of carve outs in our
workers compensation laws for real
estate agents and and a few other things
so would it makes sense uh to do these
things um and as representative kahill
Appley um pointed out making it
specifically just for who it's supposed
to be
for um in this does clean it up because
we do not want someone coming into work
and saying well here you're supposed to
do X today but go skiing and and and
we're not going to pay you for those two
hours and we all agree that I think we
all agree very that that's in
appropriate and U so uh any other
comments from any members in the lob
representative turkot you have a you'd
like to speak I would thank you Mr
chairman uh for the record I am in
support of this bill
um but also going on the record I I am
generally opposed to specific car vs
such as this but since this is a
clarification more than a uh a new carve
out I I will support it as as has
written thank you Mr chairman welcome
any other comments from anyone in the
lob seeing none any other comments from
uh our committee members on
Zoom seeing none we have a motion on the
floor of a to pass with an amendment
would you please call the role on the
amendment Mr uh seaworth seaworth votes
yes Callum tellum votes yes Mackie votes
yes Nunes Nunes votes yes Warden Warden
votes
yes turot turot votes yes Boyd Boyd
votes yes Huff Huff votes yes Melvin
Melvin votes yes
josian toosan votes yes Sullivan
Peri
you're muted I don't know if we've lost
him he's he's muted Ry vote
Yes my screen uh kahill kill votes yes d
sylvestro d sylvestro votes
yes Schmidt Schmid votes
yes Tumi Tumi votes yes buard who should
I vote Yes
agant yes infantine infantine vote Yes
Amendment passes 20 to Z Amendment
passes 20 to zero next motion on the
floor is ought to pass with Amendment
anyone like to
comment seeing none the motion to pass
uh Mr Clark uh seaworth seaworth votes
yes Callum Callum votes yes mcky votes
yes Nunes Nunes votes yes Wen won votes
yes jot
Kut votes yes voyd boy votes yes Huff
Huff votes yes Melvin no votes yes
josian corosion votes yes Sullivan suvan
votes
yes Susi Susi votes yes Rudy Rudy votes
yes kill aill votes yes d sylvestro d
sylvestro votes yes schmith Schmid votes
yes Tumi Tumi votes yes Bard Bard votes
yes vot yes infantine infant timee votes
yes 20 to
zero Mo uh the motion passes I to pass
with Amendment 20 to zero without
objection uh place this on the consent
agenda thumbs up from everybody thank
you very
much
give it a second here for the clerk uh
bill super John Mack he's got it going
House Bill 348 requiring employee public
notice or new amended collective
bargaining agreement recognize Len turot
for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I do have
Bill like to introduce
or recommend an to pass with an
amendment I do have an amendment
0047 okay we have a motion on the floor
we have a second by representative
Nunes okay um you are recognized to
speak and move your motion uh your
Amendment and what is the amendment
0478 we have a second on
that representative
Nunes your um Rec Rec to speak on your
your motions thank you Mr chairman um
the amendment as well as the main uh
Bill itself is about one thing and one
thing only and that's transparency of
the negotiations
process uh between the public
employer and really the
taxpayer
um as well as union
members what the Bill does is it
requires a 30-day period between a
tenative agreement being
reached and a TA
being
signed as a collective bargaining
agreement and how that is done is both
the a notice that a tenative agreement
has been reached as well as a copy of
that tenant agreement shall be posted on
website we heard
several uh speakers who spoke against
this they were
all uh there were a couple of
uh representatives of the Union heads
Andor one of them a New Hampshire
Municipal Association uh spokesperson
who was also a
labor and their their
entire effort appeared to
be
um wondering why a 30-day period was
needed in between the TA and the
collective bargaining agreement again
this is for
transparency it allows the taxpayers
should they choose to actually look at
it before it signed and allows the union
members to look at it before it is
signed
um some of the other things that they
talked about which kind
of appeared to me to be nothing more
than trying to throw the issue out for
or or kind of do a slight of hand really
was they talked about not knowing what a
tenative agreement was quite honestly
anybody who's a union head or somebody
in the municipal Association they don't
know what a tenative agreement is
position they also brought up the fact
that it was going to delay things by 30
days um I made that abundantly clear
several times that if you know you have
a 30-day waiting period you filled that
into your negotiating process you start
early or you just remember that you have
that
30-day waiting period they also brought
up the fact that uh there would be
confusion people reading it well to me
anybody who goes into look at that is
going to be smart enough to understand
what's actually in there the final thing
that uh they kept saying over and over
well everybody gets to see the
collective bargain bargaining agreement
it's posted on the New Hampshire Public
employer Labor Relations Board well yeah
that's that's after the fact that's
after it's signed that's after the
Collective Agreement targeting agreement
is
done
and the I almost got the impression that
it was you know need to see this we'll
take care of it and when it's all done
said and done then you can see it so I
am of course supporting this uh
transparency
Bill and that's all I have thank you
recognize individuals who would like to
speak anyone on Zoom representative
Sullivan first up representative
Sullivan thank you Mr
chairman um this bill causes a great
deal of problems for public sector
collective bargaining and I'd like to
try to explain
again there is already a 30-day waiting
period between the time that a tenative
agreement is ratified and um when the um
the voters approve it um this adds an
additional 30-day waiting period before
the ratification can take place and that
waiting period serves no purpose during
the waiting period between the time that
the um the agreement is ratified and the
time that the voters um vote on it
everyone has every opportunity to review
that collective bargaining agreement and
in the ratified
agreement um if this was
approved in 60 days prior to the um the
voters uh getting a hold of
this the um tenative agreement the
unapproved tenative agreement not approv
approved by anyone other than the
bargaining
teams would be
posted during that posting period people
could review it and if they complain
about it and the parties um change it
that would result in a new tenative
agreement and a new 30-day waiting
period that 30-day waiting period would
push past the other waiting period and
the um collective bargaining agreement
could not be Pres presented to the
voters um if the voters don't get the um
collective bargaining agreement for
approval that means that the parties
will go probably a full year without an
agreement um
so I don't know if you you ought to be
starting or providing for 90 days or 120
days just in case someone complains and
the uh agreement gets changed during um
prior to ratification so this would be
highly problematic and I would point out
that the municipal Association
represents
employers so both employer and employee
um rep
Representatives find a a problem with
this bill um I implore you not to
support ought to pass or the amendment
for that
matter thank you any other comments from
seeing none any in the lob chamber
representative seaworth you have a like
to recognize to speak thank you Mr
chairman um as I listened to the
previous
representative advocate for his position
he may have convinced me to uh vote the
other way he proposed a scenario where
um a tentative agreement is reached but
when
the um stakeholders if you will got a
chance to review that tentative
agreement they came back to the
negotiating team identifying problems
with that agreement and actually
convinced the negotiating team that they
had they had not reached a proper
agreement and sent them back to to come
up with another one it's hard for me to
see how that's the wrong outcome
uh don't we all want to see absolutely
the best agreement that can be
reached um and and more eyes if more
eyes improve that process I can't oppose
that thank Mr chair thank you any other
comments
here representative Nunes you're
recognized thank you Mr chairman I know
people probably can't hear what I'm
saying can you hear representative Nunes
any thumbs up can you could you hear him
just speak okay well why don't you hold
off representative Nunes I'm going to go
grab one of these speakers and put it in
front of you
okay no it's all right do some playing
around
here it
back it's like David Letterman used to
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
now um
um I have a question for representative
turkot if I may um wouldn't this just
mean that if a a tenative agreement is
made and it's not settled then upon a
new ten tenament agreement the 30-day
would start
again I can answer that yes yeah
absolutely and I think going to
representative Seward's point and maybe
your point that would give the two sides
the
uh influence is the wrong word
uh to get it right the first time I
guess is a way so when you come with
your sentive agreement to post it for
the 30 days the best thing for both the
the union and the public employer is to
come with a an agreement that's going to
pass muster with the taxpayers and the
union members thank you thank you
representative representative kahill you
recognize thank you Mr chair um I'm
wondering looking at all the Amendments
that various members of the committee
brought forward
today um is it should we have a higher
standard for the people coming to these
agreements that they have to get it
right the first time and that you know
they have to get have another 30-day
Penance if they find
something I'm sorry representative K was
that your comment or question of cot I
didn't I apologize I was watching
something here it's all right was was
that just your comment representative
kill that was my that was my question to
representative
turkot I didn't real I thought this was
an EXA it's supposed to be a lot of
times this isn't q&as a lot of times
we comment then was introduced I
it it has been
my practice on some things to have a
clarification if someone asked for a
clarification it's not supposed to be a
debate amongst each other it's a time to
speak your mind about the
bill um someone can always decline I
always like to try to keep it so if
someone has a question um that is truly
clarifying and trying to to get an
answer so would you please
um if you'd like to restate if it's a
clarifying type of question
representative kahill uh representative
you know may or may not want to answer
it or but I would rather not have a
debate if that's
okay uh well uh no I'm just I was just
pointing out that you know sometimes
people in their best efforts fall a
little bit short need to revise
something and that was just the point of
my of my uh
comment understood thank you very much
representative Sullivan I may not have
been clear enough first time around so
let me try again um if you if
you if you post it and you change it
it's not going to result in a better
agreement it's going to result in no
agreement because you'll miss that
second deadline
and you'll go past the district meeting
if you go past the district meeting
getting a special school district
meeting or special meeting before the uh
uh the town
um is rarely approved anymore so that
means that uh the parties would go a
full year with no agreement because it
blew up during that 30-day waiting
period um that's not good for the
employer it's not good for the employees
it's always better to have people
working under a current Collective Argy
agreement um so that is the problem you
don't end up with a better agreement you
end up with no
agreement thank you representative
Sullivan I have uh I'd like to comment
um I was really surprised at the lack of
emails or phone calls I received
opposing this bill um I would have
thought it would have been uh with much
more Vigor I did receive a phone call
and spent 30 minutes on the phone last
night uh with Union head and it was a
very uh polite and productive phone
call and when I said to them well why do
you have to have an additional 30-day
period why can't the same 30-day period
for the posting and the 30-day period
before the vote by the whoever the the
governing body is be the
same same time period not 30 on top of
30 you'd have an answer um against that
um I asked about the transparency
because that's the way I look at
this um I do believe since the public
pays for this they should have the right
to see it and I understand you know
there's a always a Rabel Rouser who
would would possibly look at this and
and make a Ruckus and and and try to
change it um but every once in a while
in the city of Manchester a contract is
ratified and then people read it
afterwards they see the things that are
in there and some of the things in there
where you say there's no increase in the
budget but what you did is people got
extra things which reduces their
productivity from 10 sick days to 12
sick days or this and that so while it
wasn't an increase in the budget which
would have had to been reported under
the budget process other things have
happened um and I don't like that it
happens after the fact that people find
out about some of these things and if
you everything we have to do here as
legislators we talk about transparency
transparency transparency we don't make
these little games this is you know not
like some other parts of the country
everything we do here is in in the open
every bill has to be heard everything
needs to be done correct we these
private meetings we don't make all these
deals except maybe consider maybe a h
what do you call it at midnight the
budget uh on commedia conference and who
knows what goes on there but um I was
just joking sorry um the um
so I like the
transparency I I hope that it was not
going to cause this delay because
obviously I don't want anything to not
allow a collective baring agreement to
go through because they need to it's
good for everybody when they do I am
going to um reluctantly a little bit you
know 50-50 on this I going to support it
uh I'm hoping that doesn't happen and if
there's any concrete changes that can
come out maybe it happens in the senate
or or uh Committee of conference but I I
have no problem with someone made a
comment to me that oh well we don't like
the public to get in because they don't
know what they're talking about public
doesn't know what they're talking about
they're just going to money the waters
and I hope that doesn't happen I think
90% of the people won't read this if
this does pass uh but the ones that do
it's better to be well informed so thank
you folks and I see a hand
representative SMI and then
representative kahill thank you Mr
chairman um everybody I spoke to about
this thought transparency wow that's
really a great idea we need to have
people see what we're
doing and then they said but the delay
what about the delay what's that going
to do with our relationship with our
unions and and then they said that this
is just more confusing then it would be
helpful you make a change it goes back
someone says they like it they like the
previous one the what was the previous
one this isn't clear I think this is
this is a bad Bill I think it's faulty
and I don't think we should pass it on
to anybody else to fix it um we could
certainly work on it in commit
we could try to find some way to make
this smarter but as it stands right now
this this is just not the kind of
product we should be sending out for the
house or the Senate to vote on thank you
thank you representative kahill thank
you Mr chairman and uh the previous
representative alluded to my concern is
that maybe this really needs a bit more
time a bit more research so so that we
are
are there any additional comments in the
L any additional comments on Zoom
representative Tumi you're
recognized yeah thank you Mr uh
chairman uh you know I I I've negotiated
a lot of contracts with the public
sector uh union rep and no I'm dealing
with representatives of the people of of
of that whatever community that I'm
dealing with
and uh negotiations are incredibly
complex you know you go through all
kinds of discussions and arguments over
various components of the
contract then after you get a tentative
agreement now it's put before in
nashille for example 85,000 people
85,000 people have 30 days to look look
at it any one of those 35,000 85,000
people can come up with some kind of
objection even though they're not part
of the contract negotiations but they
become part of the contract negotiations
by
by this particular bill so all of a
sudden one person comes up what two
people come up or a group comes up and
said well we don't like this and by the
way you didn't address this
thing that should have been addressed
and all of a sudden back to the
negotiations and then you go back to the
negotiations and you go through all
kinds
of months and and and meetings and and
those kind of things and then 30 more
days somebody else comes up with a it's
this is an eternal
negotiation and and this what it will
turn out to you know in many cases it
won't in some cases it won't in many
cases it will so it's a nightmare and
and PE private sector unions don't have
to deal with that and
uh and I hope that we don't make public
sector unions have to go through this
painful process thank you uh Mr chairman
represent turkot then toosan
representative turkot thank you Mr
chairman
uh quite honestly a lot of the stuff
that is being thrown out here nothing
more than fear grenades if we have an
agreement that is settled one or two
individuals in a town of 85,000 is not
going to be enough to change an
agreement you're not one or two
individuals won't do it now if there's a
clause or something in that contract
where half the town is up in arms as our
chairman mentioned before well maybe
that's the proper time to get it fixed
um to the point about private SE sector
is not having to do this I can guarantee
you that is the case I'm a member of a
private sector Union I was a negotiator
for very many for many many years and we
had a very similar situation if we
brought a good agreement to the table
between management and uh for management
and our
employees it passed we went out on roach
show we said what it was the equivalent
of putting it up on a board for 30 days
and if it was good enough and there was
an outrage it went out for a vote if
there were things in there that were so
honorous that 75% of the pilots didn't
like it guess what we did we went back
to the bargaining table uh that'll be no
difference uh no different than
this thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative toos and follow by
representative
Tumi thank you Mr chair so you know as
you know I'm filling in on the committee
but looking at the language of this bill
it seems quite simple to me that it
requires a bill to be posted for 30 days
and if a majority of the public doesn't
like what's in the content of the
agreement they certainly should have the
right to comment on that as taxpayers
they the ones that are paying the bill
so it seems pretty straightforward to me
in common sense that um that they be
allowed to to see the agreement during
that time time frame thank you thank you
representative
Tumi you're on mute representative Tumi
Len you want to here thank you Mr
chairman uh I just wanted to ask the
question uh
um that for example in the private
sector Pilots for
example they go through a negotiation
they come up with a a tentative
agreement they bring it to their members
and the public sector you bring it to
your members too at your union members
but the pilots don't have to bring their
agreement to all of the customers of the
airline for their input you know if I
was a customer of the airline why you
know I would like them to make less
money so that I my tickets are uh aren't
quite as much
but the it's not it's not the same thing
my point is
you know uh it's definitely not the same
thing and and in the case of the pilots
they're only going into one entity
they're not going to another entity in
in the public sector you got to go to
your membership and in this case not
only do you go to the public but you got
to put it in front of them for 30 days
for them to to hash out and uh
cause to act as another component of the
of the negotiations so uh I hope I'm
being clear uh but I can just I can just
see incredible problems for public
sector uh employees and employers by the
way thank you thank you any other
comments in the
L Mr chairman uh representatives bushard
and Susi have raised their virtual
hands
okay I will call on representative buard
and then representative Susie
representative buard uh thank you Mr
chairman as a lifelong negotiator I I
find and in the public sector I find
this bill very
cumbersome uh when you're talking about
a tenative agreement it's a an agreement
that is in a
process and it's not an agreement until
both
parties meet together and ratify it in
that's when it there is the time of 30
days where the public can have viewing
of
it giving the public a view of
a tentative agreement prior to that is a
matter of confusion to the whole process
because that tenative agreement
may not be ratified by one of the
you thank you representative Susi then
representative turot thank you Mr
chairman um I would just like to get a
clarification because I'm going back to
the public hearing um and I oppose the
bill but I just want a clarification
because I think I remember asking a
question at the public hearing as to
whether or not in the 30-day window um
and I negotiated contracts for the city
of Nash I was on the Executive Board of
the nashal firefighters Association for
17 years
um and I remember asking the question as
to whether or not during that 30-day
window whether or not the public would
have a say or they would be able to do
something about it so to me there's a
difference
there I believe in transparency I
believe that the public should see
Collective BR agreements I don't agree
it should be this way but my clarifica I
would just like clarification as to
whether or not the intent of the bill is
to
allow residents say in the city of Nash
may be different in towns but in the
city of Nash city of Manchester to allow
residents citizens to have
say um about things in that contract
over that 30
days it's my understanding that intent
of the bill
uh is to have it public uh so people can
review it there still uh you know you
have 100 people that don't like it it
doesn't matter it's going to the
governing body uh in in the city of
Manchester would be the alderman or the
school board and the town my
understanding is in one of these towns
it what comes up is what's presented by
the council that's the only thing they
can be voted on is what's presented by
the um so the
individuals if that's what you're
talking about repr the individual people
they can't make changes it's still the
governing body in each one of these
things they they can at least have their
voice heard to the governing body and
the governing body could do what they
want they could ignore it or whatever
that's my understanding of the bill
unless I'm represent turkot I again I
didn't want to have a question to answer
but if you're willing to answer that
question I think you just adequately
answered it but I I also have to point
out that the
discussion uh for most of the people on
the zoom call so far keeps talking about
for the public this is this not is not
only for the Public's benefit this is
potentially for the union members so the
union members have a right it starts to
make me wonder why there's such a big
push back from some of the unions and
they kept saying during the uh the
initial hearing well you get to see it
when it's signed and it's on the website
so this is this is Clarity and
transparency not only for the public but
also potentially union members just want
to make that clear that'll be the last
point of it is that all all right
represent Susi answer your thank you I
think I see a couple of hands I'm going
as quick as I can here look at all these
things I see represent to roian and then
berui I believe representative to roian
you're
recognized thank you Mr chair so just to
to comment on the earlier um statement
that um in the case of a pilot Union
contract
negotiation um it's private and so forth
and and that the customer doesn't have
have a choice if you will well the
customer does have a choice that is the
difference in a in a private sector
situation um the customer has a choice
he doesn't have to fly that particular
Airline if he doesn't like what the
airline's doing in in the the Union
contract affected it to a point where
he's not satisfied as a customer he has
other choices the taxpayer doesn't have
Cho in many cases doesn't have a choice
he pays the bill I mean he could sell
his house I suppose if it's a if it's a
property tax thing but by and large
there's not choice so therefore I truly
believe the taxpayer has the right to
see the agreement and if he doesn't like
the agreement he certainly can comment
about it to the governing body that may
or may not decide to take that um input
uh into consideration when they when
they decide what to do but at least they
the the taxpayer or the citizen has at
least the choice under being able to see
the agreement to to
comment about their
concerns thanks thank you representative
Broody followed by representative Smith
thank you Mr chairman um so many things
I want to comment on but I'll keep it
short uh first of all union members have
to ratify it so that gets that layer
taken care of before it goes out to the
public also I think you I was surprised
to say you didn't hear hear from a lot
of people I think we will if we go to
pass this I think the town clerks and
the you know small towns will come out
of the woodwork they can't afford to go
a whole year without ratifying a
contract they may have some real good
employees that are working for them and
they want to keep them the next town
over offers them more well they could
lose some good employees to go to
another town to work because they're
just getting more money or more benefits
or what whatever it is so I think it's
going to be really hard for the the
towns to set tax rates and keep
employees I'll keep it at that although
I have a lot to say thank you
representative Ry
representative thank you Mr Mr chairman
um I'm an alderman in NASA we have
our our unions come to us all of the
information that people need to make a
decision on whether or not we should
pass it is available to to the public at
that point they can come to hearings for
these they can contact us our
information is everywhere there's no
reason for these to be
posted months ahead of time because the
decisions are often made just then and
there we're very lucky to be able to
make decisions quickly if we had to put
something aside for a couple of months
that would be it would be a waste of
time it would be a waste of of Good
Feeling with the unions we have no
reason to punish them and I I would ask
when when uh representative turkot
speaks if he would please U make his
make himself visible it it would be much
easier for us to understand why he's
saying what he's saying if we could see
what he's please it's just a small thing
thank
you thank
you any other comments in the L no any
comments
online okay we have a motion on the
floor about to pass the amendment this
is the um
um the vote on the
amendment called Ro uh
seaworth SE votes
yes votes
yes Mackie votes yes Nunes nunz votes
yes bon bon votes
please restate your motion I still vote
yes thank you thank you Mark uh chot
chot votes yes voyd boy votes yes H HFF
votes
yes Melvin Melvin votes
yes ter
Sullivan Sullivan votes no Susi Susi
votes no Peri Peri votes no kill kill
votes no this won't
fly
sylvestro can't hear you
Linda votes no thank you schmidi votes
no
Tumi tumy votes no buard buard votes no
Adent
to9 the motion has um passed the motion
at hand is ought to pass with
Amendment
yes sewor votes yes Callum Callum votes
yes Macky votes yes Nunes Nunes votes
yes Won Won votes yes turot turot votes
yes void void vote Yes Huff Huff vote
Yes
[Music]
Melvin
roian Roan vote
Yes Sullivan Sullivan votes no Susi Susi
votes no Rudy Rudy votes no kill kill
votes no sylvestro sylvestro votes no
schmith schmith votes no Tumi Tumi
no who
votes
no V
notin I vote
Yes 11 to9 in favor motion passes 11 to9
um please uh
um submit the um blur I assume there'll
be a um minority blur please submit that
to Sullivan and he will get that to me
they have a
name already you can put me
put next bill is uh House Bill 448 a
committee to establish a study thatare
Federal occupation health and safety act
standards with the safety and health
standards of New Hampshire Department of
Labor uses for public sector employees
this house go 448 eight I I
recognize representative Huff for a
motion thank you Mr chairman I need to
uh render House Bill 448 inexpedient to
legisl the motion of Flo is inexpedient
to legislate is that
seconded second seconded by
representative turot representative HF
are recognized to speak on your motion
chairman this study idea has come in the
past I believe and at that time it was
deemed to lead to a very large cost to
municipalities if uh gone to
fruition um to switch the state to an
entirely new system would be very very
costly and at this point in time I think
that would lead to an unnecessary
bureaucracy and an unnecessary expense
for the
state that's it thank you have any
anyone in the lob wish to speak on this
bill seeing none anyone on
representative Sullivan followed by
representative infantine representative
Sullivan thank you Mr chairman um just
like to clarify this uh study committee
has not come up in the past um there was
a bill that came up last year um it was
um a full commitment to go to public
sector OIP um I acknowledge there was a
problem with that um and it was unknown
what the costs might be um or the
benefits might be because this will also
result in federal money coming back to
New Hampshire if we make the commitment
the study committee is not a full
commitment to do public sector OIP what
it will do is it'll provide valuable
information as uh Deputy Commissioner
Ogden
indicated the Department of Labor will
finally know how their safy standards
compared to the um uh the oosha
standards they don't have a full
understanding of that now and um the
Deputy Commissioner has told me that um
they can't make the commitment to do
that study unless we tell them to um so
this um this bill tells them to do the
study um we'll give them valuable
information and will let us make an
informed decision down the road as to
whether or not we want to commit to do
public sector oi um we I should have
proposed this last year I'll acknowledge
that um but um I believe that this this
will will provide very valuable
information to the state of New
Hampshire about our public sector um
safety um so I ask that you oppose the
um motion of itl thank you thank you Mr
Sullivan um I am going to vote against
the motion of itl and hope to uh vote on
a motion of ought to pass um I'm an
insurance agent by trade uh safety is a
significant part of my business I have
had three deaths of my clients um have
had three deaths over my 20 year 20 30y
year career um and
uh I think one was mechanical failure
and two were were uh employee mistakes
uh um I Haven an 10 certification card
um I learned some valuable information
about that when I was a teenager I used
to work on a masonry crew anyone's ever
been down on Amber Street in ashaa knows
all those concrete buildings and block
buildings down there well I was a Mason
tender on those things let me tell you
we did some dumb things back then like a
monkey jumping around on on uh on
reinforcing on on staging one day some
guy had a bucket of mud as they call it
mortar and they bring it over and he
hits the the the scaffolding so hard I
wasn't sure whether I was jumping down
or jumping on the
building and so I'm not proud of that
but those things happen now we we all
know about wearing our hard hats and if
you're six feet to trench you have to
have a ladder that goes three feet above
and all these other things we do so
people don't
die and some of it's really really
simple no one should go to work and
die you know it's just that's way I feel
about it to do as best you
can why does a municipal worker have to
follow not have to follow a rule in a
trench with a hard hat with
glasses um
that a private sector employee does I
don't know what Richard Nixon thought of
in 1972 when he created OSHA um if he
meant that to be but um you know I got a
lot of hard time from my fellow
Republicans years ago
when I voted to disallow smoking in
restaurants will How Could You Dare do
that it's business's choice so well no
not really you name any other place
where someone would be allowed to be in
a confined space with carcinogenic
fumes now you probably have to wear a
respirator and some of the things
according to OSHA now I did say to
representative Sullivan I would support
his his bill but you know fire and
police can't really abide by that
because ocean would probably tell tell a
firefighter not to walk into that
burning building and he probably oosha
would probably say to that police
officer not to go into a firefight so
there's certain things that aren't
obviously going to fit with OSHA and
Municipal workers but a lot of things
are simple and uh I don't know about the
cost I know Maine has done something I'd
be interested in seeing that and I would
be interested in sitting on this
committee should that be the case so um
I respect anyone who chooses to vote
however they want to on this bill uh but
that's just my personal
uh beliefs from my uh my tenure and my
job and such so thank you uh folks for
indulging me anyone else would like to
speak on the
matter oh represent SMI you're too
kind I don't uh I thought you were
pointing at someone down there
representative
seaworth and I might Point your
way probably pick me up uh thank you Mr
chairman
um I agree with many of things you've
said and I'm honestly torn on this bill
um first vot sorry
sorry
although you mentioned a couple of
issues um some things with the cost I
I'm certainly skeptical and I think we
do want to be in formed about
this decision before we uh go ahead and
take it and um studying it in a
legislative committee is is probably the
right way to go um why I I'm I'm torn on
this is I've also spoken to some people
outside of the committee and
um it has been impressed upon me the
difficulty of even holding our standing
committee meetings and getting them done
in a timely manner is is a challenge and
uh I think we're doing very well here in
our committee um but the resources that
the legislature has are being
strained and my concern is with having a
study committee um that this is a lot of
work it's a lot of work for the
department and it's going to take a lot
of investment for the
legislators that are assigned to it uh
we have to convince it a senator that
that they need to make that commitment
and we need to have the time to really
go through this data and it I I'm just
worried that um if we put this forth now
in the environment that we're struggling
with it it's not going to
be met in the way that it deserves to be
met so for that reason I'm going to have
to vote
no but I it's not a rejection of the
concept it's it's concerned with the
details thank you chairman thank you I
see a hand representative Sullivan but
you look like you're Frozen oh there you
are no just sit representa Sullivan
you're recognize for
motion take the opportunity to try to
persuade my friend uh representative
seaworth um number one
um most of the work is going to be done
by the department you are correct it
will be a lot of work for them I see the
the committee as not having as much
heavy lifting to do because they'll be
primarily overseeing what the U
department is doing so um that's number
one number two um this bill very
intentionally um gives until um November
of
2022 um for the report to to come out um
because it is a lot of work and it also
gets us beyond the um uh the pandemic if
necessary um so um it gives more time um
and um enough time to to get the work
done and um I think and if we wait till
next year we won't have the luxury of
two years because uh we'll be coming up
on the end of the two two-year term and
this is a bill that really works best in
the first year of a two-year term so
that there's enough time to make make
the study and I have to tell you that um
perpetually enthusiastic um uh Rudy
Ogden um Embraces the idea of doing this
study um um but he simply needs to be um
given the the go-ahead by um uh the
legislature to do it so I U hope maybe
I've turned your head a bit
any other comments from any members of
the committee in the
lob seeing none any additional online I
see I see representative Broody you're
recognized thank you Mr chairman um this
is going to take a little time a little
effort but how much time and effort is
it for us to sit here and discuss
something compared to somebody losing
their life or somebody getting in an
accident when they're paralyzed for life
or just getting hurt severely hurt and
not be able to work anymore I think the
time and effort that we put in is is
much easier than somebody that's going
to struggle through a bad accident thank
you thank you any other questions uh I I
don't see any hands I saw a thumbs up
from Michael Cahill but I does that mean
you're
okay oops sorry that was endorsing the
comments of Representative barudi
understood I see no other questions I'm
going to call a rooll the motion is
itl um Park please call the role
seaworth seaworth will
vote
Yes Callum Callum
yes Mackie yes Nunes Nunes votes
yes Warden Bon votes
yes turot turot votes
Yes
toosan toosan vote
Yes Sullivan Sullivan votes
no
Susi Susi votes
no Bui buudy votes
no Jill Jill votes
no sylvestro sylvestro
no schmi votes no Tumi Tumi
no buard buard
no
Ed VES
10 uh the
uh being a tie the bill is open for
additional
motions Mr chairman I'd like to make
motion motion of the floor is a to pass
by representative Adent in the uh is
there a
second second by
uh representative
buard U motions out for comment any
comments would you like to speak any
motions thank you Mr chairman I think
this is a good B and I think we got pass
it clearance to S thank you
representative any other uh
representatives in the build in the L
Zoom seeing none if you're in favor of
the motion you vote yay if you're
opposed vote nay you purp please call
the
rooll
seaworth seaworth
no Callum Callum votes no McKie votes no
Nunes Nunes votes no Warden Warden votes
no turot turot votes
no boy vo votes no Huff Huff votes
no suvan suvan votes yes Susi Susi votes
yes Rudy Rudy vote Yes
Jill VES yes d
sylvestro vot
yes Smith SMI votes yes Tumi yes T me
yes buard buard votes yes Adent yes
infantine vote Yes vot is 10 10 so what
we have here is a situation where the
bill will go to the floor without
uh not really a blur it's a
recommendation uh paragraph to be I'm
sorry represent what do you call it
specifically it will go without
recommendation correct but then then
each individual each one from either
side of the vote uh will write um a blur
but I think it's their recommendation as
to why the bill either ought to pass or
should be inexpedient to
legislate so um
uh represent Hoff if you would write one
on behalf of of the uh itl and um
I'll representative Sullivan will grab
will let us know who will be writing one
in favor of the oop pass correct put me
San I want to hear one more Bill uh on
the executive session then we're going
to take a five or 10 minute break if
that's all right with everyone
um the next bill in front of us is House
Bill 563 established committee to study
a living wage utilization of Public
Assistance among low wage workers and
their families in New Hampshire to
recognize Brian seaworth for a motion
thank you Mr chairman um on this one I'm
not Tor and would like to make a motion
of itl motion on the floor is itl it's
seconded by re nope I did not hear the
bill number Mr chair I'm sorry
uh 563 representative Nunes
motion um so you're you're recognized to
speak on your motion thank you Mr
chairman
um sometimes a study committee like the
one that we were so divided
on uh seeks information and helps us
make a better decision other times when
I read a study committee I can see the
results that are uh intended for that
committee produce written right into the
bill and um the way this was presented
there I think there are some interesting
questions about wage about cost of
living um but I'm really uncomfortable
with the assumptions that are loaded
into the front end of this study and I
cannot
support thank you
there any representatives in the the L
like to comment on the on the
motion I don't see any any
Representatives
online representative SMI followed by
representative
infant thank you very much I'll be very
quick because I know everybody could use
a little break um I'm an alderman in
NASA and I can see the effects of uh
minimum wage and near minimum wage on on
the people but but I can also see the
effects on our soup kitchen The Strain
on our nonprofits organizations that
take up the slack in the local economy
um because many of uh our jobs are
service service jobs um and and that
creates low-wage worker uh that lives in
in our city a strain on the library that
provides services the welfare department
um so many jobs pay less than it takes
to actually live here or live past one
flat tire or one visit to the doctor so
uh every year a minimum wage Bill comes
through and we hear this about it and we
hear that about it but we don't hear how
it actually affects the state it affects
people but it affects the businesses it
affects the cities it affects the towns
it affects all of us and so an
opportunity to look at the whole picture
really isn't leaning towards one way or
another it's actually looking to see
what we need to be a better State I'll
leave it at that and thank you for
listening thank you representative
Smith um I'll wait I'll wait and speak
to the end anyone else like to speak
online I guess I am all right uh I have
no problem uh in fact I agree with some
of the comments representative Schmidt
made um I made a call to the Department
of Labor and Department of Employment
Securities and I asked them if they had
the bandwidth and the people to do this
right now given the issues that
department of labor and employment
Securities are dealing with with Co and
while they would be willing to do
anything that we ask them to do they
they have other things for other
individuals to do right now they feel is
more pressing so we continue to talk and
it was mentioned in the hearing uh and I
have pulled off the
um I have here I this is for Hillsboro
County MIT on an annual basis produces a
very nice report and on this report it
goes every state and every County within
every state and provides a living wage a
property W excuse me poverty wage and a
minimum wage and it provides it in the
categories of an adult with no children
one children two or three two adults no
children one two and three then they
talk about all the different things in
the typical expenses they outline the
expense of food Child Care Medical
housing Transportation uh taxes all
these things for the same categories
adult with no children one two three two
adult know children one two or three
children this is extremely detailed
information and I didn't yet not know
that this was out there um and I think
it would be really duplicating the
efforts I mean this you know you know
maybe I'm wrong I think the MIT guys are
pretty pretty smart guys and they have a
lot of good things and and one of the
comments made to be on one of the
Departments is we don't have the
economists and we don't have the the the
ability to do this as well as they do um
so for the for the for the reason that
this information I wish someone had
brought this information to me I wish I
had known about it a while ago I know it
was mentioned I didn't really take note
of it in the in the Committee hearing as
much as I should have but there's a
tremendous amount of information down
here by County for the entire State of
New Hampshire again repeating myself a
living wage a poverty wage and a minimum
wage uh and and at this point the
information is here available and and
really um don't want to take away the
resources away from um the Department of
Labor Employment Securities at this time
um so I'll be voting uh in favor of the
itl representative Sullivan you're
recognized thank you I'll be very brief
um you and I had a chat about this and
um uh the
um that MIT um uh data is is very
valuable data um but they're only
because they're doing it nationwide it's
difficult to do it as thoroughly as
would be helpful and uh a uh County like
Graft in is very diverse um it uh
includes towns like uh H Hanover and
Lebanon with uh probably quite High um
uh living wages um and then um a town
like Woodsville which uh is a completely
different type of economy so I I think a
study like this could drill down a
little bit deeper than what the MIT MIT
does and I would expect that they would
probably use some of the MIT data um to
um launch their their effort so um but I
I I agree with you on the MIT the value
data any additional comments from the
members of the committee seeing none any
recognize yeah that there's a another
component to to this bill and it has to
do with uh people on public assistance
in it it's say sad that anybody that
works fulltime or close to full-time has
to be on public
assistance but it's it's you know really
important that we know what scale of of
of of that is happening and it would be
very valuable for us to make arguments
about it but on this another aspect of
it too is that if an employer has isn't
paying enough and his employees have to
go on public assist
he gets a competitive advantage over an
employer that gives uh good pay and
benefits and uh I think that information
needs to be known for whatever reason
you know it's I think it's important
that we know how much the public is
paying uh for paying benefits for for uh
employees thank you thank you any
additional uh individuals wishing to
speak on the behalf of this bill on uh
on Zoom representative
buard um thank you Mr chairman uh that
MIT calculator is a great resource and
I've used it in the
past uh in establishing my opinion when
it comes to a minimum wage however I am
supporting this bill for another reason
so that we can find out what does it
cost as
taxpayers for having all these low wage
workers that we have to provide for them
I think that is something we need to
have a study
about thank
you thank you I don't see any other hand
on zoom and I don't have any
hands in the L so I'm going to call the
vote Mr clerk if you are in favor of the
it t l you vote Yes if you oppose you
vote no
Seth yes
Callum Callum votes yes mcky votes yes
Nunes Nunes votes yes Warden Warden yes
turot turot yes voyd voy yes Huff Huff
yes Melvin yes
Troian troan yes
Sullivan Sullivan votes no Susi Susi
votes
no
Ben
Rudy it looks like he may have exited on
accident oh there he is connecting to
audio
okay I'm sorry we had an accident um and
Fry votes
no uh K Hill K Hill votes no D
sylvestro
no can you say it one more time please
Linda dest votes no thank
you uh schmith Smith votes no
do me no
buard Bard no agant no INF time in time
vote Yes V is 11 to n v is 11 to nine
will there be a Minority
blur just let me know if there'll be a
minority blur thank you I'm going to
take a 10-minute recess um we're going
to leave the microphones on and the
camera on here
so watch what you say and uh we'll back
you
yes
[Applause]
yeah
for
e
hey Brian if you're definitely going to
V with firefighter
build then why are we going to do the
itl and then overturn
[Music]
it
I just took down
that
[Music]
yeah
yeah I think I got it right a couple
things so representative nunus you have
more fun here or over in
Finance well ways and mean oh ways and
mean sorry this is this is my home I I
came to labor last term so this is this
is like you know I don't get to spend as
much time here now because I'm between
two committees I get a I get a little
lost sometimes but U but no it's good to
be back in labor again must be difficult
doing two committees I have a hard
enough time with one well that that's a
very heavy committee yes and the time
commitment is several days per week so
um um I'm happy to help out but it does
you know sort of put me in a situation
where I have to run down the hall we get
back and forth each each one and
hopefully that'll straighten itself out
as we go through the through our first
year of this plan financing Ways and
Means are just unbelievable the
commitment you have to make to those uh
and then Mark Warden will tell you how
uh last year mark you had 80 bills in
Commerce or something like that I think
they should break it into Commerce one
and commerce
two workload in Commerce so when when
you're when you're a freshman you don't
know
anything they uh say do you
um well what Jun do you want to be on
someone say well what has the fewest
amount of bills you know and you never
know though well we've had I don't know
uh representative Sullivan's online here
I don't know how many you guys had the
last four years here um that I wasn't
here but I think about 25 was the the
the highest 25 or
[Music]
30 first year of the session we had a
heavy heavy workload last year the
second year second year of the term we
it was a little bit
lighter all right if you folks um are
ready uh some of you try to come back
put on your uh camera so I know you're
there because we're going to be taking
up in a minute or so House Bill 2 31
relative to workplace location rights
just want to make sure uh representative
Warden are you with
us all right all right if we're all
ready to go I'm going to reopen
reconvene the uh executive committee I'm
going to call recognize representative
kahill for a motion on House Bill
231 uh thank you Mr chairman on House
Bill
I'm moving itl and with some regret I I
know that the uh woman who brought this
forward to us Kate Fredericks has worked
on this for several years but I think
that the uh bill and the Senate will
have much better chance of passing and
accomplishing much of what she wants to
do and so I uh am moving uh to itl on
231 motion is made by Gill seconded by
representative seaworth do you want to
speak your motion
now representative kale you kind of did
I'm sorry I got ahead of myself that's
okay that's all right um anyone else
like to speak in the L on
this anyone
online this is will infantine I'll just
uh mention I did receive a call from the
senator who sponsored the other bills
and and the other um and uh I had a chat
with her and she said the uh um she felt
that the other bills had been worked by
uh many other groups uh and a consensus
had been made um I agree with you no
disrespect um to the woman that spoke
very eloquently uh in front of us in her
ordeal uh her ordeal while I'm sorry she
had to deal with that has probably made
uh all future situations regarding this
um better for everybody so we're not
dismissing her at all by iing this bill
representative Sullivan
um just wanted to mention that I I
received a call from um that same woman
I'm forgetting her name um but
um the uh what I encouraged her to do is
get together with this the major
stakeholders um that that have worked on
the the Senate bill and if she has
concerns about the Senate Bill work with
them to come up with uh uh Solutions um
but don't ask us to combine two bills
because we'll just screw it up um so um
the um I'm hopeful that that they will
do that and if there are um improvements
that can be made in the Senate bill that
they be made before they uh well maybe
when they come to us um but um at any
rate
uh hopefully we'll get a bill passed on
this I think it's a very worthy
cause agreed any further questions
online on Zoom seeing no hands in the
committee room the motion on the floor
is inexpedient to legislate uh if you
are in favor of the
motion say I if you're oppos say nay CL
may call the role seaworth seaworth yes
Callum Callum yes Mackie yes Nunes Nunes
yes Warden Warden yes turot uh turot
yes Boyd Boyd yes
yes Huff Huff
yes Melvin yes D
roian Coran yes Sullivan Sullivan yes
Susie Susy yes Rudy yes Rudy yes kill
kill yes P
sestro vestro
yes Schmid Schmid yes
Tumi T yes buard buard yes P
yes infantine infant timee yes 20 to
Z more 20 to zero any objection to the
consent
agenda um before I say that um I know
we're all trying to get things done um
quickly in the consent agenda however
based on the topic I
[Music]
think I'd like to put out there that
maybe someone should at least speak to
let folks know we're not abandoning this
issue uh that is up to everyone to make
it if they would like that I just don't
think it should go on a consent agenda
at least should be stated that this uh
issue is being uh dealt with through a
Senate
Bill uh just throwing that out there any
thumbs up any thumbs down don't care
Michael uh would writing a blur uh
suffice yes please yes it would I'll be
glad to all
right thank you just wanted to put that
out there um the next bill on my list is
House Bill 501 establishing a minimum
pay for adjunct facility uh
representative kale submitted a
significant Amendment to the bill
skipped
one
[Music]
did you skip uh
231 we just did we just did 231 oh I'm
sorry 107 right I I apologize I'm um I I
was going too
fast House Bill 107 relative to a
minimum wage minity wage I I call on
representative turkot for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I moved uh House Bill
107 itl
is that motion seconded seconded by
representative Huff you may speak to
your
motion uh thank you Mr chairman um much
like many of these minimum uh minimum
hourly rate bills that we've done over
the past many many years uh pretty much
the
same same arguments I'll put forward
against them uh against the uh 22 2250
per hour wage that this one calls
for
um primarily there's always this and I
find it's not with just the minimum wage
bills but many other types of similar
bills like this there's always the
desire to insert ourselves politicians
Andor bureaucrats in between the
employer and the
employee uh and basically when we do
that we just muck up the relationship
that exists there that was with an
M
[Music]
um just for clarification
cl
to we we had several businesses and
associations who have testified to this
bill uh specifically and to many others
uh about the ne negative effects of
going uh up to a 2250 an hour uh minimum
wage and I I must of course agree with
that um today's wag is out there in the
in the in the free market where supply
and demand determines what a individual
is
worth um
produces wag is far above uh even a
couple years ago my local Wendy's down
at the traffic circle in Lee has sign
up part-time $12 an hour to start part
time um everybody's favorite Whipping
Boy or whipping horse or whatever you
want to call it Walmart even they they
recently raised their starting wage to
12 for part-time they at their uh they
range for their hourly now 12 to $25 an
hour and this is a company that
employs more individuals in the United
States than New Hampshire has
citizens 1.5 million jobs that company
creates I know everybody loves to hate
them but that's a lot of jobs that
they're providing to a lot of people
that might not even have work
without Walmart being around so based on
that I I'm a free marketer I believe in
letting supply and demand deter
determine what an employee is worth and
letting the business and the employee
determine uh that Arrangement so I I
recommend against that or I in favor of
the itl motion thank you very much Mr
turot I have a few hands up I'll get to
everyone represent
Adent thank you Mr
chairman um I'm Gonna Save as much of my
powder as possible for the $5 an hour
bill um I think that one's better
structured um it's got a phase in period
it's more closely aligned federal
minimum wage uh potential increase um I
don't know what the process a budget
reconciliation is going to look like
when it goes to the Senate it survived
in the house but who knows um I my
problems with this bill are just the
dramatic increase um with
no um no phas in Period um even the
example that I mentioned the other week
um where Florida took the large step of
doubling theirs from $8 an hour to
almost or $25 an hour uh still period
there and it's still only up um so it's
not that I don't support folks making
2250 I think that's you know pretty
close to what someone would need to uh
survive in certain areas um I think 15
is a good
floor um that's what I'm going to argue
for um so I'm going to end up voting
against this today um and I look forward
to seeing um when 15 gets scheduled
depending on what happens in DC um and I
have just
one thank you any other comments here in
the
L uh I saw a few hands on line if you
wouldn't mind again please uh
representative Smith then representative
Smith
oh you're muted still on mute I was I
was unmuted I muted myself I I don't
know uh you you brought up the MIT wage
calculator and if you really looked at
that closely you probably could find out
that in nasua the wage calculator thinks
that you can find a studio apartment for
a single person for
$1,082 a year that's
$840 and if you can find anything I mean
maybe a garage Loft with no heat it
might be
$800 but there you go I just wantan to I
just want to make it clear that no
matter what you're saying about minimum
wage it really should keep Pace with the
rest of society or cities like Nash are
going to have to pay more into their
welfare department more into their souit
kitchen and this is a discussion that we
need to have it really is and by by the
way Walmart is the largest employer in
the state of New Hampshire and if we're
paying the most employees around $12
that's hurting the economy because those
people can't go out and buy shoes for
their kids or go to the restaurant and
enjoy themselves and be part of the
community and I don't know we really
need to do something because we're going
backwards with this and I'll stop
talking there thanks very
much thank you repr SM representative
kahill uh thank you Mr chairman while I
while I don't support the 2250 I do
think that uh that's probably pretty
close to what a person would need to
survive you know on their own and
without a roommate and or or a partner
to share expenses uh I don't think we
can find an $800 apartment in New Market
either um
but when I'm thinking back to you know
to Walmart now they know that they're
big employer and people go there because
it's cheaper but do you remember how
many small businesses there were
providing these products and services
before Walmart became this
Behemoth I think those are a lot of jobs
that were there and having them all
conglomerated into one place isn't
necessarily a good thing for our economy
country thank you representative kahill
are the other questions on
Zoom seeing no other hands any questions
here in the
L seeing none the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
107 if you are in favor of the motion
you'll say I if you're against you'll
say nay Mr clerk please call rooll
seaworth seaworth votes yes Callum
Callum votes yes thank you votes yes
Nunes Nunes votes yes Wen Wen yes turot
turot votes yes Boyd Boyd yes Huff Huff
yes Melvin yes D
roian Roan vote
Yes Sullivan votes
yes Susi Susi votes
yes Rudy Rudy votes
yes kill kill votes
yes d vestro sylvestro yes Schmid Schmid
says
no yes Tumi says
yes
buard buard says yes agant agant says
yes infantine infantine vote Yes I vot
is
objection seeing n uh seeing none thank
you all right next guys I have to speak
frankly because I don't know if I've
made a mistake
here
um uh for the next bill I'll save that
mistake for the next bill the next bill
in F in uh before is House Bill 501
establishing a minimum pay rate for
adjunct facilities of the University
system and community college system of
New Hampshire we had a hearing on this
bill uh we were ready to execute today a
major amendment has been provided to us
uh was my the opinion of the uh chairman
and the vice chairman that it was so
significant a change that it should have
a hearing so we are not going to be
executing House Bill 501 today until we
can at least have a hearing on on that
Amendment it basically stripped out the
entire Bill and came up with a new
paragraph
any
objection okay the next one could be a
mistake on my
part we have House Bill 385 FN it was my
intention of calling representative Susi
for a
motion um and I just want to make sure I
can do this correctly I apologize for
not giving you advanced warning we have
an
which
is 2021 -03
07h but parliamentary wise this uh I
don't remember guys so we got to refresh
my memory if I'm doing this correctly
this was submitted by representative
Pearson the um Prime
sponsor are we able to have a
representative move that even though
the amendment is not in his
name my opinion is yes um that because
we have the amendment number that after
the
fact if it gets adopted by the committee
then it gets redrafted as the committee
Amendment that's true we did that the
first correct we did that the first one
today with House Bill 258 we didn't have
him so all right so sorry thank you for
letting me uh you know think out loud
there uh representative Susi if you're
willing to make a motion on uh House
Bill 385
FN I will do so I just have one question
of the chair yes seeing the bill I I
don't believe that it was stated in the
calendar that we were executing that
today um is that going to be an
issue it um it was not and I had emailed
everyone about 385 FN and 590 FN that
they would be executing and um our um
calendar uh does State
[Music]
um I was told I got to make sure it does
State
um chairman executive session on pending
legislation may be held throughout the
day time permitting from the timeing
committee is in initially convened is is
the uh was my understanding the clerk
has acknowledged that that is sufficient
to bring forth other piece of
legislation I will also tell you if if
folks do not want to hear the those two
bills today they may automatically die
because they have to be out by noon on
the 18th and we are not scheduled to
meet between now and the
18th so I believe we have made all the
appropriate um measures but I have a
question of the chair from
representative turot inquiry Mr chairman
yes um I I don't really honestly care
which way we go on this on whether we
hear it or not I want to be sure that we
are following um is what is in the
calendar does that give the public the
required
notice that they are supposed to receive
that's my only question
Point uh I am happy to do what majority
of the committee would
like uh under the understanding that
maybe not the house bill 385 because I I
don't know why I'm getting this but I've
been told that 590 must be out 385
doesn't even though they're both FNS
don't know why I I don't want to push
that luck and I would like to hear both
um based on what I have been told uh but
this is the speaker a the Aaron goule
because the sentence I
read and because I notified each one of
the members of the assoc of the uh
committee that we can have that I am not
above committee
[Music]
um uh wanting to rule otherwise I see a
couple hands I'm going to so that my
answer to your question representative
turkot uh since I did give notice to all
the members and because that blurb is in
there
um I can get a ruling from this I can
get a ruling from from the clerk house
clerk again I I really don't care I just
want to make sure what you're doing
is accordance with public notice not
notice requirements and all that that's
my only Point as do I representative
kahill you had your hand and then
representative Smith yes uh thank you Mr
chair and I while I know that this is
not our normal practice to exact bills
without you know an interval in between
I you've you've articulated that the
reason behind it and the fact that these
bills you know will be delayed and won
you know need to be out and the uh the
dis the standard disclaimer that
executive session may follow I believe
covers the concerns of my friend
representative
turkot representative
Smith that's exactly correct we've been
doing it that way for the last couple of
sessions that that little blurb tells us
that we can at any point in time once
it's been um at a hearing once once it's
been at a hearing we can do it at any
time we like and since it's already had
its hearing this one can go
ahead okay thank you both of you um out
of courtesy to any of the members is
um does anyone have a
uh just any kind of an issue with not
point I believe the outcome is going to
be a positive uh so for the one the ones
who don't want it it may not be could an
outc come but
um all right I'm going to go I'm going
to go forward then um anyone here would
like me to get talk to the clerk just to
verify I'm happy to take a fem minute
recess I did talk to him beforehand he
seemed to believe but I'm happy to do it
again if there's any anyone
whatsoever as a
concern fine I don't see any so I'm
going to move ahead with House Bill 385
FN and um recognize representative Susi
for a
motion chairman um I would to um how to
pass with Amendment on H
385 um and I'll move Amendment 307
each do we have a
second
second um cart is second the motion
representative Susi you
are recognized to speak on your motion
and move on uh your Amendment orce your
Amendment 2021
d307h thank you Mr chairman so I think
the public hearing I think there some of
the I think the water got muddied a
little bit I think there were some
things that were said in there about uh
the death benefit this and that I took
Tuesday and I talked to
um Deputy Commissioner Ogden I've made
some phone calls I talked to you Mr
chair
um in in a nutshell this bill is pretty
simple
um we're going to move that age of 65 to
70 based on some of the um what we heard
in the public hearing that day and I
think some of the confusion comes
in understandably understand this there
are a lot of people that are working um
longer
today that section c is going to change
the age to 70 if you look right above in
in the law I don't have
um but in section B it says that at the
time of somebody's retirement the
benefits would expire five years after
that uh his or her 65th
birthday knowing that I think um former
um representative horn when he
originally put the bill in
um wanted to move that age to unlimited
I don't think we can go unlimited um
however that fiveyear window comes into
a lot for people that may work we may
have firefighters at work till 62 or 63
years old and my question was to Mr
Ogden as to whether or not that fiveyear
window would really only give these
folks um two or three years to P um
pursue a what we call um an occupational
health injury I don't think it doesn't
change anything else in the bill what
it's doing is it just changed that age
of 65 to 70 um and that pretty much in a
nutshell I'll try to answer question if
people
ask thank you Mr chairman thank you do
we have anyone else that would like to
Zoom not see any anyone in the lob like
to
speak representative turkot thank you Mr
chairman
um I
believe we were together when this first
passed few sessions ago when it was
first put into the that is correct um
into the rsas and I believe at the time
I was probably for I honestly don't
recall
um I'm not opposed to the concept of
what's going on here my my concern is
and that's the reason why I will vote
against it not because of what it is but
I I don't like the potential for uh the
creep of the aid
um I mean originally the original Bill
took out any uh length of time and now
it's it's uh been you know moved up to
five years my strong concern and worry
is in next term we'll be coming back and
it'll be another five years and another
five years and another five years so
that's my only concern again the concept
I was here when it went in I was fine
with it I do have concerns about age cre
in the Bill thank you Mr chairman very
well any other comments in the
committee no uh I will speak after last
but no one no one here in the committee
would like to speak I see representative
kahill would like to be recognized
you're recognized represent K thank you
Mr chair and I also support the bill and
I just have another you know because of
this question of age grp I I've heard
now I'm hoping this can be retroactive
far you know lifespan and energy and
everything and it may be too late for me
but I just want to just put that out
there thank you representative Hill any
other comments from Members online on
Zoom seeing none and in the committee
room representative her
uh thank you Mr chairman um I just
wanted to say thank you to Mr Kill
because I turned
that sorry I called you representative
herel versus representative n Mr
chairman I get called a
lot trust me sure we all do no
problem um I don't see any other I would
like to just briefly speak um I do
recall representative turot when this
bill first came up and um understand we
talked about a carve out earlier
um the skiers or the the the instructors
this is another carb Val no other
industry is allowed to have a
retroactive or post uh injury Workers
Compensation Plan you must be injured
while at work you retire
today that's it if you got hurt last
week you better tell about it last week
because you retired today and it it's it
okay so we have carved out something
specific for the firefighters now
doesn't take a genius uh you know it's
pretty logical as Spock would say to um
assume that someone who goes into
burning buildings for 20 25 years of
their career has a higher propensity to
get lung type diseases or lung cancer so
this carve out was made I believe the
intent when this was because this was
much bigger much more complex as you
remember or turot brought down to
something very specific um and um I
think the intent was that the 65 may
have covered you know everybody up to
either age of Medicare or Medicaid or it
was going to be plenty enough because a
lot of these guys were retiring at 60
but the bill technically says five years
out of retirement and I will take the
Union at their face value that they're
telling being accurate that because of
new pension reforms meant to elongate
their pension plan uh some are starting
with a different plan some are starting
later some are working later so for
someone who's going to be not
necessarily A A on the on the uh on the
truck firefighter who's going into the
burning buildings but ones that are now
uh captains District Chiefs Chiefs that
could be you know still working albeit
not necessarily you know going in the
building um that they could work till 5
so the 70 was a good compromise which I
recommended yeah the hearing didn't go
too well it was kind of dis
misunderstanding about a death benefit
there really is no such kind of a thing
except when you know a burial type
benefit uh if you die for work from a
workers um on the job situation but I am
too uh I will say this just for the
record I too would not want to see
anything come up even if I'm retired
from this chamber I'd probably come up
and testify again saying we made a deal
this is what it is we all agreed let's
stay with the deal H maybe 10 years from
now people are working longer and you
know we all find out that the the covid
vaccine makes us live 20 years longer
well hey okay we can look at it so
that's probably way too much so I will
quit seeing any other come on guys you
know I get anany here I gotta say
something every once in a while um
anyone else have any comments seeing
none here the motion is uh on the
amendment house uh Amendment uh 0307
H um if you're in favor say I oppose say
nay Mr clerk would you please call the
rooll the amend seaworth seaworth yes
Callum Callum yes Mackie yes nunz
no vo vo
roian d
roian
no
solivan
yes Susi Susi yes
Rudi Rudy
yes Jill Jill
yes P
sylvestro yes Schmid schmith yes Tumi me
yes
Bard
yes ENT
yes the amendment vote of the amendment
passes motion on the floor is ought to
pass with Amendment it's open for
further
discussion seeing none Mr clerk would
you please call the rooll
seaworth seaworth
yes Callum Callum yes Macky yes Nunes
Nunes
no Warden Warden no turot turkot no boy
Bo no hu Huff
no Melvin
no
Sullivan suan yes Susi Susi yes Rudy
Rudy yes kill kill yes d sylvestro d
sylvestro yes schmith schmith yes Tumi
tumy yes rard rard yes ENT
yes infant time
time uh
yes V is 13
passes you provide any blurbs in favor
or against as soon as possible in the
old days uh we used to sit here and stay
in the room until everyone kind of fixed
them up because we want people going
home and forgetting them I would like
them by next Wednesday if possible
please give you some time over the week
weekend uh if I have them in Wednesday
morning uh some of them could be in the
calendar
um no it's not going to beat you in the
20 yeah it would be nice to have yes we
have to have them in the calendar so I
have to have these
by I'd like to have a Tuesday evening so
I can approve them all by Wednesday at
noon and get them over to where they
need to be so they can hit the
calendar I have a question I'm sorry I
have a question on the committee reports
yes is there a form that is sent to us
or is that just a how do we how do we do
the committee reports um I would
appreciate if you would email it to
representative Sullivan and he will get
them to me okay it's all going to be
email uh we're not going to have our
little yellow sheets for a little while
guys thank you I don't think they've
developed anything online when emails
will be sufficient at this point Thank
you thank
you how house the last bill that we will
FN relative to paage sick time
recognize representative turot for a
motion thank you Mr chairman uh
I Rise uh for an itl motion on HB 590
F uh you uh
your motion is next to legislate do you
have a second representative Huff second
motion you are um I recognize to speak
on your
motion thank you Mr
chairman
um at first look uh looking through the
bill it's it's obvious this goes well
beyond on uh something as simple as paid
sick time there's just so much added in
here that alone for me uh is enough toh
send this to
itl however uh much like the minimum
wage bills or some of the other P Paid
Family Medical Aid
bills once again this Bill Gets In
Between the
employer and the employee the employer
and the
employee have the ability to make their
own uh contracts between them within
them between
themselves um for the legislature or bu
bureaucrats to get in to start mandating
laws for sick time for all businesses
when one business is going to be
definitely different than a uh a small
business going to be definitely
different than a big business um for us
to get involved with that I just think
again is is not our our place um sick
time vacation time all those things were
originally implemented by businesses as
a
benefit and now um legislature or some
of the legislature want to make that
stuff mandatory um and I'm I'm just not
in favor that we had many once
again individuals who testified against
this bill most most who were in the
business uh world and one eloquent
gentleman who did a really nice job
talking about what can happen and what
can happen when this is done properly
and what happens when it's done
improperly
I believe somebody also mentioned during
the hearing that the majority of
businesses already have um paid sick
time and that's again a benefit that's
worked out between the employer and
employee so I uh rise against this bill
and recommend
it thank you
representative thank you Mr chairman um
want to kind of lay out a little bit of
background um on why I don't think itl
is the right motion
um so when we were hearing testimony
during public hearing um like the member
said uh we heard from
businesses that were already doing um a
time off uh Pally um and that's well and
great um however
there are a lot of employees and there
are a lot of folks who don't have access
to that um I've worked jobs in the past
where I haven't had access to that and
actually one specific example that kind
of radicalized me on this issue was um
in 2018 I worked for a rubber Factory
and this is a multinational corporation
they have the potential and capacity to
offer a program like paid sick
time I was working third sh one night um
and I noticed it was about summer so
bubs were around and I noticed all of a
sudden my skin started to itch really
really bad um just you know had to put
down what I was doing just violently
scratching my back all over no idea what
was going on I felt my throat start to
get a little tight and when I looked at
my arm I realized it was not a bug b I
was breaking out in hives and my throat
was closing up and I approached my
supervisor asking if I could go to the
hospital because I plac barely a high
enough premium on my life for that and
he said you can go to the hospital but
if you leave it will count as one of the
three days off that you get a year not
paid sick time just three days that you
can miss if there is an emergency not
rolling literally 38 hour
sheets
and what bothered me about that I ended
up going thankfully um but just the fact
that this company that could definitely
have just you know wash that away they
were fine um put an employee in a
position where they were first of all
concerned about the longevity of their
appointment um but then had to make a
decision between getting paid for that
evening and living I mean not to be
dramatic but I went to the hospital
because I was concerned that I was going
to die if I didn't get out of whatever
was causing that allergic
reaction um I'm I'm grateful for the
companies that do provide a paid six
time benefit um what we're talking about
though are generally employees that make
somewhere between 8 n $10 an hour they
tend to be lower on the
rug um we did the math the other week
works out to about $640 to
$700 um a year per employee um which
might sound like a lot were they not
just a conversation on the other side of
the street where the governor was
outlining a plan to scale back the
business Enterprise tax this year um
just you know a lot of those folks who
don't have access to that pain sick time
they're not the permanent managerial
class not people who have access to zoom
and um can do their jobs remotely they
folks that have been you know dealing
with the nonsense of the last year in
grocery stores really doing front line
stuff they're not asking for a lot
they're just asking not to get the
disease on other people at work because
they have to choose between a paycheck
the longevity of their job and infecting
other people
um so I would really love to see this
OTP however I'm mature enough to
recognize that the votes for that
probably don't exist in this room and as
the chairman uh said when we had this
hearing and he was speaking to
representative aler said I'm a
republican so I have concerns with some
parts of this but I like other parts of
this and I would love to see a situation
where we took another look at this bill
we took out some of the stuff that's
obviously not going to pass in a
republican majority that's fine but we
kept some of the stuff like protections
for domestic violence victims or stuff
like that so I know it's an ask and I
would very much appreciate if the itl
motion fails I will immediately make a
motion to
retain and then I will volunteer to
we'll cut out a bunch of the liberal
stuff in Bill we'll try to get stuff
that we can all agree on and we'll try
to move something forward in the house
that keeps those domestic violence
Protections in there keeps other good
stuff in there um so we don't just end
up throwing away the good stuff in the
bill that the chairman was avert to so
that's my ask I'd ask folks to vote
against itl and then like I said I'll
immediately make a motion for a routine
so that we can go through find stuff we
all want um I just I think that's the
most productive Way Forward because I
really don't want to lose that
that thank you for your
testimony any additional any
representatives in the L that would like
to
comment individual members of the
committee online show hands if anyone
would like
to
speak I have representative Sullivan
then representative kill representative
Sullivan
you're still muted uh
Brian yeah I know we all did that I'll
figure it out um um I was um beginning
to say I believe this is a good bill as
written um I think it's a reasonable
benefit uh not overwhelming um and um I
believe it U warrants the uh support of
this committee thank
you thank you representative kahill
thank you Mr chairman um I would concur
with representative Sullivan I I know
that we heard from the uh business
Community but we also heard from a lot
of uh members of the public who just who
are working in these jobs without the uh
benefit of a sick day and and I think
that the uh you know the about that you
you know one hour per every 30 worked is
is not an unreasonable ask uh in fact we
you may be familiar that I I I uh
I was quoted in many Publications uh you
in response to the question about
whether businesses should uh uh could
afford this and I perhaps I should have
phrased it differently you know that
they should perhaps reassess their
business model but uh aord was the
operative word in the discussion and a
Gentleman called me last night and he
was giving me a pretty good pretty good
talking to and we had a discussion and
15 minutes later we were we parted
amicably even though I I'm not
businessman I've never had an employee
uh I'm not now nor have I ever been a
member of a union for the benefit of
some who may be curious um but I just
think that we we have an obligation to
to be balanced and to try to address
concerns on employer and employee and
that's what the labor committee is for
so I'll be voting for this
Bill thank you represent kahill do I
have any additional
speakers online on
Zoom right the chair I'd like this
representative oh Brian represent SE
chairman when I
uh was was told I had the honor to be
the vice chairman of this committee I
was pretty happy because I get to sit up
here at hook Porton but the chairman
gets to do all the work and uh so it's
always great being Vice something
however there is one duty that's buried
in the house rules that is up to the
vice chairman and that is to review the
bills for constitutional issues and
advise the chairman uh when there is
one and uh that actually came to mind
because one of the bills we worked on
earlier today has this carve out for
municipal and County workers that I
believe is due to constitutional article
28a um which says if you're going to
and I I'll actually get the words right
here if the state shall not mandate or
assign any new expanded or modified
programs or responsibilities to any
political subdivision in such a way as
to necessitate necessitate additional
local expenditure so back when when this
article was fresh the legislature at
that time when we passed broad mandates
on employers that increased the cost of
doing business we said we have a
responsibility here either to fund that
with State funds or to exempt the
political subdivisions and here is a
case that yes mostly we're thinking
about the private
employers um that pay low wages but I'm
sure this impacts uh towns and counties
and we haven't considered that
and I will be voting against it for
other reasons as well but my duty
according to the rules is to inform the
concern being
informed um I don't see any other hands
I'd like to make a few comments
um I
believe that employers should pay for a
certain amount of Si
days I believe the employer should make
that decision on their own I believe
that people a good employer which I try
to say that I
am uh needs to do what he do what's
right by his employees in Pay benefits
and sick time to retain his good
employees
and to have a good working place I am
very proud of a good working place not
everyone feels the same
way
um but I would rather there be an
incentive I think this bill is not
really a sick time but this is a family
leave Bill this is a kind of a a water
down family leave Bill and I think that
could be taken care through disability
because I'm an insurance guy and I think
there's a a way that can
happen but on this bill
I would much rather see
something where someone came to me and
said an employer if they give each
employee up to five sick days a year and
they can revolve two of those a year to
the next year or three to the next year
if you take a quarter of 1% or a half a
bet because we should
encourage as legislators and as a
government we're not the government I
guess but we kind of are uh to
incentivize businesses to do this now
not every business can do it but at
least if we give them an incentive they
will some are already doing it will'll
get the incentive some that don't
necessarily do it will then do the math
$20 an
hour 72 hours plus you got to add
another 30% on for FICA and Fuda and
unemployment you know some of these
other things so it's it it you know it
can get up there um for a small business
uh my nephew who has you know just
started the business two or three years
ago has three or four employees just
starting out um that might be a lot give
incentive off as a business Enterprise
tax and and that might might do
it I also believe as I I'll stand behind
what I said which represent Adent
commented uh we have uh there are some
things in there great you know for the
uh
um
[Music]
someone who is being
stalked or or something like that we
actually have a similar law in New
Hampshire for unemployment you can get
unemployment because of some of the same
reasons domestic violence stocking
things like
that um one of the things that kills me
penalty when we make laws for businesses
we leave it up to the Department of
Labor for the most part a vast majority
of the violations for
not adhering to labor laws is you go in
front of the government you go in front
of the Department of Labor and they'll
find they'll deal with it being able to
have civil penalties I I always have a
problem with that I can't think of one I
know there's a couple um if you tell
someone to do something
dangerous uh go go go on that well sir
my harness you know is isn't is is
fright and broken I don't care go do it
anyway and gentleman gets hurt or dies
that passes it can go through the
corporate veil to both the corporation
and the personal some of the few things
that are out there um but I don't like a
civil penalty
um I'm sorry I can't give you what you
want representative um I would rather
come back as an incentive of bill um I
believe if I'm mistaken you feel free to
to correct me right now isn't there a
similar Senate
Bill also that will be coming to us or
that it's over there to be dealt with on
the same issue as uh PA sick time I
think there is but um I don't know
that's the only reason I wouldn't go
with the retention so uh I'd really love
to have every employer offer sick time
it is very good for
everybody
government shouldn't decide it but a
giving an incentive would be and Walmart
gets thrown around a
lot and as you know I don't like Walmart
I boycott Walmart I'm probably the only
one in this room that boycotts Walmart
because of the way they are um so you
know they are what they are
and you
[Music]
know they deserve the reputation they
have uh Enough Said by me uh
representative kill
thank you Mr chairman and and I have to
be honest did it did not had not
occurred to me that this incentive might
be the better way to go I I didn't have
anything to do with writing the Bill but
I think you know if we did put this into
a uh some sort of a work session maybe
even this term it could be done uh if
not certainly retaining it this could be
something that most of us could agree on
and solve a big a big problem for many
state thank you K any additional
online seeing none any comments for our
members here in the committee
room seeing none we do have a motion on
the floor of inexpedient to legislate it
has been seconded you in favor of the
motion say I if opposed say nay Mr CL
please call the RO seaworth seaworth
votes
yes Callum Callum votes yes Mackie votes
yes Nunes Nunes votes yes Wen Wen
yes turot charot
yes boy boy
yes off off
yes Melvin Melvin votes yes
yes Sullivan Sullivan no Susi suy votes
no Rudy Rudy votes
no kill kill votes no d sylvestro d
sylvestro votes
no schmidth schmith votes no Tumi do me
no
bard
buard votes no I wasn't unmuted sorry
head
no
disappointed vote is 11
passes
no
[Music]
yes add will you be complet theary
you all right I have no other items on
the um
agenda
um um we will be meeting probably
Wednesday is I it's March 4th where we
will have one hearing for
501 and then we will look to
um have an executive session on on a
number of the outstanding
bills
um well let me let me just officially do
this I I close the executive session and
then so that's Clos and U representative
San asked me why I did not call both uh
minimum wage bills uh
today and um I want to see what's going
to
happen in in
Washington um so there's things going
back and forth I'm not going to need the
debate on the good bad or the ugly it is
what it is so we're just I wanted have
some time to see what was going on uh
that was the reason why I recogniz
courtly representative to me um so we
will be exacting those remaining bills
um and uh try to get your
blurs to me by Tuesday evening so we can
have them ready on Wednesday unless I
get a text here from I'm just going to
check my text to see if I get a text
here from Heather telling me no they
have to be in sooner I'm waiting for you
Heather if you are listening but it
probably would help her to have it in a
little bit sooner um it did last year um
if you just um made it a day earlier I
think that would be and we we've got
plenty of days to do it if everyone can
get them to me on Monday evening great
you know I'll I'll deal with Tuesday
morning but try the weekend try to get
to me on Monday um I would appreciate it
those are the only comments I have
representative tuny uh Tumi you've asked
me recognized thank you uh you said if
unless I misunderstood you you said
Wednesday March 4th uh Wednesday is
March 3D right I I I apologize I may
have misspoken I meant Thursday I'm
trying to keep us consistent there are
certain people have a job jobs and they
want to be able to uh first of all I
don't want to keep people out any more
than they have to be um to lose a day of
work and I want to keep it consistent
because many people have a situation
where they work every Wednesday or every
Monday or or something so I'm trying to
keep it consistent with a Thursday
representative to
me thank
members I appreciate everyone's uh
cander uh and polite
um way they handle themselves today not
everyone's going to get what they want
what they want all the time but we try
to make it professional um here as best
we can so I do appreciate uh
much